you hey welcome
everybody to the h3 podcast
the number one happening place to come
and feel good at the party and just
feel hype all the time and be stoked on
life
all these other podcasts you watch you
put on you're like this is depressing
this podcast they are
not funny or insightful like a street
podcast is
i'm all of those things and more i'll be
whatever you want just please
keep watching today we are joined by um
logic the musician the artist
and uh the the rapper of
one of my favorite guests we've had him
on before he's a friend of ours
we have a fantastic conversation
he's in a really good place with his new
album that just came out
which i believe was is his sixth
studio album uh no pressure it's called
and it's being critically acclaimed
everyone's loving it including myself
great conversation there this episode is
brought to you by
ridge wallet and i also want to give an
announcement before we throw it to logic
is that we have this new members program
our schedule has changed a little bit
you guys may have noticed
we are now going to be posting our
episodes on monday
and thursday those are going to be our
two weekly
episodes at 8 00 a.m for the working man
i'll tell you guys why we're doing this
i went in youtube analytics you can see
a heat map
of when people are watching your channel
the most and we just
we were kind of fascinated to find out
that people are mostly watching
our content during the week starting
early morning because these these people
these are working
salt of the earth people we were posting
on the worst days
saturday is the worst day to post
content for our channel
so what we're doing yeah is monday
thursday 8 a.m is when the podcasts are
going to go up
and then for members we are going to be
doing a friday
live stream for members only
so the friday
live stream is gonna go up for members
only
it's a third extra episode and um
really i have to emphasize that for
non-members nothing changes it's the
same two episodes every week
the third episode is kind of a new beast
where we take suggestions
from the audience we take calls from our
members only discord
and we can besides that we're going to
react to content that
we would normally cut from our podcast
which is stuff that like might get us
mature rated
or might get us claimed and we always go
like oh it's not even worth it so why
bother
that kind of stuff we can throw in there
on the friday live stream because
we don't have to worry about algorithm
suppressing our video
or some copyright trolls blocking it
worldwide or something
i wonder if they could block our that'd
be weird if they blocked our vod
the vod of the stream yeah i mean that
happens that could happen
well anyway the vod will be available
for members
i know i know people are upset that
we're making content behind a paywall
but you really just have to understand
that like
we're in a situation when we've lost a
lot of our sponsors
and we really need to um just create a
stable
a stable baseline for which we can make
uh continue to make our content and
expand the podcast and buy stuff like
the gatsby
and
what's something else we've we wasted a
lot of money on something else didn't we
we we did but it has not been right oh
yeah we have something really big coming
up that we've wasted like
way more money than gatsby next week
it's exciting and like dude there was
this
you guys remember that tiny little um
mobility scooter that couldn't go up the
curb
and like just so we found out you can
buy six of those for how much was it
like fifteen thousand dollars
yeah yeah yes there was a minimum order
they only sell them in six packs like
it's toothpaste or something
maybe we can find another vendor that uh
that sells them individually but um
but anyway the point is that uh
need we we really do need to foster so
we can
continue to maintain and invest in the
pod
and uh we want to reward those people
that that really do want to support us
there and
to give them a really quality experience
for for them so
if you you know we're going to post
highlights so if you want to get
a feel for for what's going on there we
will be posting highlights
but otherwise we're just really thankful
the people that do support us directly
like that
and so we want to make a really nice
quality product for them so we'll be
doing that every friday
i think around 12 this week's a little
unusual because we're recording an
episode on friday which we're
generally not going to do anymore but
we're going to be doing it the first one
this friday at 2 we said right dan yeah
uh again because we're recording an
episode where
we have an interview with um with andrew
yang um that we're recording on friday
and
we're doing him and unfortunately it
couldn't be moved and we're doing him at
noon so
it's kind of awkward we're launching
this on the on the first week in a kind
of an awkward way but moving forward
it will be at noon on friday probably
around the pacific time i guess we
should specify
12. probably around three but we'll
tweet it out and stuff so
and the vod will be up for members
so but but for if you can't afford it or
you don't want to subscribe
you get the same two episodes those are
our main episodes
like the ones we've always been making
you're gonna get the same content you
always have
there's an extra episode for members i
think it's gonna be a lot of fun
and i do hope to see you there but you
can always catch the highlights
i know that was a lot to get out but i
needed to explain that there is
something i do
really want to watch before we get into
logic which was i could not stop
laughing i was literally can't even
watch this because i just i die when i
when i watch it i was just crying every
time because
there's so many details i got no audio
dan
and the audio's really important but
it's still funny as [ __ ]
uh i saw this video on twitter and i i
was just
crying and then i opened it like two
hours later and then i
thinking that like i got it out of my
system and then i was crying again
like there's just there's someone here
let me just play it
audio
so this lady's trying that
what is this like sonic like what kind
of job
[Laughter]
you can hear him like the wind gets
knocked down
like he hits [ __ ] so hard you can hear
the wind get knocked out of him
watch
[Laughter]
and the fact that it's blue slurpee
exploding everywhere
oh and then the lady record you get this
blue
slurpee and drink what is that i think
it's just slurpee
i play sonic's it's known for it's known
for like having weird drinks and stuff
what's the point it's called sonics it's
like a fast food places
there's nothing in that way for somebody
how do you react to that how do you not
laugh at your mom
[Laughter]
so and then
i think they're just recording because
they it's like such a novelty
did somebody bring food on skates
these guys getting up to get the food
listen to the later recordings
[Laughter]
anyway how do you react to that
i saw a comment it just said uh
you just clock out and never come back
at that point
yeah you think so just bounce yeah yeah
no i would just leave
i would escape into the sunset never to
be seen again what do you say
what do you do you help them up or i
mean you definitely have to laugh in
their face as much as you don't want to
funny as [ __ ]
dude he aged so hard he hit his back so
hard
imagine how much he's getting paid for
this [ __ ]
he's probably getting like seven dollars
an hour
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's gonna be the lowest point in his
life and now it's been recorded
look at his legs he just
he just eats [ __ ] so hard
okay anyway
nice pause
anyway so i installed a button yeah i
got you hooked up
i said dan can we get that so like
anytime i want i could just
oh i can't see it yeah it's just i'll
just play it on screen
anytime i want i could just hit a button
and we can we can roll it out which i
think
i'm not exactly sure the situation but
we can't see it so is it just full
screen
did i just do it you can hear
everything come out yeah it just it just
fades in and just shows the video on
facebook
so that's a new feature yeah for
everybody it's a video drop
we had audio drops now we got video
games
i can't see it but i can hear it i'll
hook you up in the future with
a uh with a source monitor so you can
see
oh my god so that's anyway that's all i
wanted to say
with that being said we have logic on
deck
so uh with that oh without it i mean i
already said with that being said how
much more do i have to set this up
without further ado that's it well i
already said with that i don't it's like
without being said without further ado
it's like dude just cut the logic so
with that being said without further ado
logic with us today
is the um bobby hall
d bobby hall aka logic who has just
released his
sixth and final studio album
no pressure uh and i'm happy to say i'm
very excited
and i am with them critical acclaim
everybody is loving the album i've
listened to it several times
i love it it's great thank you so much
so good it's it's a it's a fantastic
uh album i appreciate it i put a lot
into it
beyond that beyond that he's also now a
dad
so what does that make you you are you
are yourself a junior a bobby jr yeah
and your son is named also bobby
yes he's the third so are you a g you're
now a junior and a senior
yeah it's kind of i'm like it's like a
it's like the um
yeah i don't know that is that's a weird
thing to think about i never thought it
was
[ __ ] my mind right now yeah you've
transcended the junior
uh does your dad call you junior
um i don't really talk to my dad but he
would just call me bobby
just bob bob you know yeah i love the
name bobby
we even we were considering
that name at some point for a girl
though
oh yeah b-o-b-b-i-e i actually have a
funny story about that
to start [ __ ] off so my buddy
um or i'm not trying to flex but jj
abrams
oh [ __ ] you know jj yeah that's my dog
i was texting him one day and he was
like yeah i'm here with roger lin and
roger lin is the creator of the mpc
and the [ __ ] like the lindrum and all
that [ __ ] that you know
dilla and so many of us make hip-hop
beats on
and i was like no way tell him i like
thank you for everything and then
he got him to write me like like a
little note
and i was like oh my god i can't believe
it this is crazy so
it said uh you know to bobby thanks for
using my
instruments but he spelled it
b-o-b-b-i-e
and i didn't give a [ __ ] i was like i'm
still gonna frame this and put it in my
studio
so then so jj was like cool i'll mail it
to you
and then mind you this is pre-corona
this is like nine months ago so he's
he's uh
or a little longer than that and he said
he's going to send it to me and then
like
a month goes by and i text jj and i'm
like hey
so uh don't forget to send that thing
and he's like oh dude i already sent it
you didn't get it so it got lost in the
mail oh no
because of the spelling yeah no it just
got lost
no no no cause cause jj sent it to me to
everything normally but just uh roger
lin [ __ ] my name up and spelled it
like a woman which is fine whatever
sometimes i feel that way i'm just
kidding
so um so
after i told jj that he was like don't
worry i'll get him to send you another
one and i'm like don't know
like don't bother this guy and he's like
he's fine he's my friend so he
formally types up a letter right and
then signs it
this time because i was joking with jj i
was like can you make sure he signs my
name right and he goes no problem
and then he sends it to me and he
misspelled
abram's in jj abrams
it was just really funny it was
hilarious probably not that maybe it's
not that funny
you got it you got it it's spelled
correctly
yeah but he [ __ ] up jj's last night he
spelled it like jj abrahams
[Laughter]
man you know it's good that they
corrected the spelling because people
would not have believed it was yours
they'd be like man you got this off the
internet i actually do have a
frank sinatra sign um piece of art i
don't know where it is because we
are still unpacking but um it says tabab
from frank
and then signed sinatra and um a fan of
mine nanisha got it for me like
years and years ago and i really always
that's an awesome gift
yeah yeah pretty cool so you're a father
now
i recently became a father you know that
actually our son now is like well he's
he's getting
he's like a big boy he's like a monster
one year and
almost three months yeah how old's your
son like six months
six and a half months yeah how is it
dude i can't believe it that it
already all happened last time we hung
out you guys like
i think you just told us that she's
pregnant
and yeah um was it the last time we hung
out when we got swatted
yeah yeah that was awesome we had to run
now you now yeah now you guys are
talking about it but the funny part is
people don't realize that you were in my
theater
yeah and you got a phone call from a
random number and
and i was like and you were not gonna
answer it and i was like let me answer
and you're like no no no and i'm like
just let me answer it
and i answered it and i'm like hello and
they're like
this is the police and i'm like here
[ __ ] off yeah yeah
remember truest story yeah and then i'm
like telling the police to go [ __ ]
themselves because we think it's just
like
somebody leaked your number or something
as they do right you know and
and the officer sounded like a kid too
so it really didn't help we really
thought we were just being pranked by
kids at the time a lot of people were
caught
we [ __ ] up we had i picked up alfredo
and on his dog tag it had our home
my cell phone number so people kept
calling me and [ __ ] around that time
actually no
that was before alfredo oh it was oh
you're right it was it was before
my number's been on this yeah it's yeah
where are you i don't ever expect i
don't ever answer unknown calls so
i was like oh i'm [ __ ] this person
calling me yeah i never do it either but
i just thought if it was your phone
i've never done that there was no money
though for a minute yeah except
we were driving home at 100 miles per
hour crying because we saw shredder
and then walking out the front door on
our ring yeah
yeah that was so sad but being a dad is
awesome yeah
yeah i love it it's a every day is new
and it's like you don't really
understand it unless you
have kids or like you know have people
in your family that you watch grow up so
it's like really cool to
man every day like one day he's he can
now he can flip on his tummy now he can
flip from his tummy to his back now he
can like all these different things like
now where he's eating pureed food and
[ __ ]
and he's he's like chewing and i'm like
it's
really it's a beautiful thing and i love
it um
balance is also extremely important
because
since i'm my own boss it's like
difficult because technically i could be
there every single day
you know what i mean but i also need i
still have to create as a creative and i
still have to provide for that family
so sometimes that's like can be a little
difficult
to have to really make sure that i'm
giving myself personal time because me
and my wife we have a schedule
so i work throughout the week but then i
still kind of clock out and come home
uh after those hours and spend the
evenings with my wife
some days are you know like a day a week
is just for me
a day out of the week is just for me and
her and a day out of the week is
a hundred percent all day uh 6 a.m to 8
p.m
family time so it's important bobby's
world
yeah dude double meaning now that's cool
yeah that's good you guys do that
it's really important to have a schedule
with a kid like
i never thought we could do it but you
just have to they
the kids need it yeah well you know
excuse me um
i got this crazy acid reflux bro and i'm
drinking coffee and it makes my
throat all mucousy i probably shouldn't
have done that for the show probably
sometimes dude it's not the thomas the
mucus in my throat all caked in there
like a
[ __ ] in my throat just to make it
more
more disgusting
[Music]
my acid reflux [ __ ] so what what it is
is um yeah it's super hard because with
the first of all with the covid
me and ela are at home like you know 95
of the time and it's super difficult
because
a lot of times like we have a nanny
during the day
and so i'm in my office trying to work
and then every time theodore walks by
and he's like dad
and it's so hard not to want to spend
all the time with him
but it's really it's hard on him too
because like it would be easier if i was
just gone
right for the work day and then came
back and you knew i was home but he
doesn't understand why sometimes
i can be with him and sometimes i can't
it's it's tough
yeah it is tough it's really it's like
you feel like you're a bad parent
but yeah it's so hard not to give him
the attention when he's like ah
so excited to see you like yeah but my i
mean that's what i talk to my therapist
about she just goes
as long as you're you know your child
looks at you and they they're smiling
and they're happy when they see you or
with you you're a good parent
i mean like as long as you're doing
you're doing what you can for them but i
think it's yeah it's important to
provide and
it is it is more difficult uh in well i
mean i might say more difficult
it's also very difficult for a single
mother with two kids to go work you know
13-hour 14-hour shifts so she can pay
her bills so i get it but i'm just
saying there are these
it it's also very difficult to know that
your family's right there
but you know you gotta do [ __ ] h3
podcast
yeah no for sure right now we're sorry
stay right there
i just gotta get it out because this is
yeah we can cut that out right there cut
it yeah yeah
oh my god don't cut that out
um so did you guys know it was like a
thing that last time i did the podcast i
said gnarly like a million times no i
didn't know that
no yeah look it up on the internet you
can find it i don't know
how that happened i was just like gnarly
everything's gnarly i didn't notice
i think i was just really excited and
nervous and that was like a tick
so there's like compilations of you
saying gnarly a bunch
i'm sure it exists should i watch it
no i don't know okay i don't know that'd
be fun to watch but i believe you
you say you're nervous but you really
don't look nervous so i almost don't
believe you
i think it's because i'm a professional
so like
you know this is what you do like i'm on
you know
but i'm not because i'm still myself i
feel like i feel like i'm this is
basically me i mean you guys know me
right
so personally so this is how i am yeah
but it's just a little different i don't
know how to explain that you just watch
what you say
every little word yeah you want to piss
people off funny thing is though is now
since i've retired from music i don't
really give a [ __ ] anymore
because there's like this disassociation
between
um ego and caring what other people
think and then when you actually leave
the [ __ ] behind
you you realize a lot of things one you
don't really exist you're just a form of
entertainment for people they don't
really view you as a human being
so when they say nice things [ __ ] up
things whatever
it's more about this persona and not
really you personally
and when you step away from that
limelight and that
you know part of the industry it allows
you to take that
so easy like there was this dude um do
you guys know anthony fontano
yeah the melon yep the melon so he
like is really great at what he does but
he would review my music ever since my
mixtapes and it would always like [ __ ]
me up because he would
always basically say how i wasn't like
good enough you know what i mean like
well
this isn't this and this isn't that and
da da da mind you he wasn't just totally
[ __ ] on me he would give me like
credit like if something's good he would
say it's good
mind you it's just his opinion right
but i find it really funny that after i
announced my retirement and stepped away
now me and this dude like text
each other and [ __ ] now he's like i
consider him like a buddy like i'll text
him about fun [ __ ] like video games or
music and we just talk and everything he
could have ever said about
logic doesn't matter um and having that
sense of freedom is something that's
actually really beautiful
but i think it's kind of also ironic
that when i'm like
all right [ __ ] it i really actually
don't care i mean i
i care i don't care 98
there's still that two percent as a
creative that cares what people say
about you right you can never
fully do it but it's just i find it
funny that now that i don't need that
acceptance
this album is doing great and everybody
loves it it's kind of funny how that
works
totally thinking about that it's just so
funny
um i mean yeah should we talk about well
even melon gave you a good review
you know what i mean yeah and i was
happy and i was really happy for you
that uh
because you know i've seen his he's been
brutal
his reviews when it's negative and i've
thought about
what is it's got to be so hard to be the
artist that is being criticized because
yeah it doesn't matter if it's not good
you know it's still a person and like
just to have to hear your work being
criticized yes
in such detail it's gonna be so but the
funny thing is like not good to who
right anything you can be interested in
you'll find others who are so it's like
yeah i actually so i did this soundtrack
from my book right
and i just had fun and if you really
listen to it it's just
all songs that i wrote
while i was falling in love with my my
wife you know what i mean the
woman in my uh that gave birth to my
child so it's like
it's all from the heart and i've met
people that are like oh my god that's my
favorite album of yours because i was
falling in love at the same time or this
or that and then there's other people
who just hate it
um but it's like what is that it's it's
subjective but
i believe even the great melon also
knows that you know like
and that's why i love that in all his
videos it's always you know this is just
my opinion
right which i think is which is really
important but
bro yeah he's torn me up but he's also
shown me a lot of love but it's also
when you are that artist
it feels like the whole world is on you
everything is you you you but it's like
dude he like
destroyed chance the rapper like he's
trying to break
he's destroyed so many artists before
and it's just like
i don't know it's kind of entertaining
when well it sucks to be involved
you know it's like the drama the youtube
drama it's great to watch
it's horrible to be involved in and i
can say that from my
side many times but you know from the
creative
yeah i have that same reaction too it's
like
it it's just so painful at times to to
get that
feedback but like and to and to know
like oh they don't hate me
right they don't it's hard to separate
that and know like oh they don't hate me
i'm not a bad person because i made an
album that they don't like
it's weird to have to say that but you
feel like a bad person
yeah yeah i've i've been in
on madison square garden sold out
everyone there to see me
and then you feel like a failure because
like my last album before this one
confessions of a dangerous mind
a lot of people said that they like
hated it because it was just a bunch of
turnip music for the most part it was
just me like just rapping
to rap and just like kind of having fun
and not really overthinking it and then
people were like you can't do
this like your logic like you can't rap
this way like you have to be lyrical
miracle guy
and all this [ __ ] so then they were like
you're oh this sucks this is terrible
mind you the people that said that it's
just such a small sect of people on the
internet
in a cove of you know this like loud
minority because i'm like okay
you can say those things but i'm i just
sold out the garden
you know what i mean like i just sold
out an arena of people who are screaming
lyrics
to the song that you don't like because
it's very popular
so knowing that and being in it is very
difficult now being on the other side of
it
it's like who gives it doesn't [ __ ]
matter i made a bunch of money and had a
blast
what's wrong with that you know but it
is funny to see
there's two sides of it right because
i'm like bobby tarantino
i make my trap music and all this other
[ __ ] and then there's a fan base there's
a part of my fan base that goes
no we like the super hip hop [ __ ] don't
do this but when i do the super hip hop
[ __ ] the people who want to turn up [ __ ]
go
what are you doing we want to turn up
[ __ ] and then when i make some indie
rock [ __ ] and i'm having fun
everybody's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing but i i step back
and i'm happy to know i'm not in a box
and i'm not making the same song
in the same album over and over again
i'm actually trying
different [ __ ] and because of it i'm
happier and now i look at my career
it's about 14 or 15 projects
full-length projects in a row sometime
once a year every year sometimes twice a
year for the last 10 years now 11 years
and i have no regrets
yeah and that's important yeah i feel
like the big theme of the album
was just all the expectatio all these
people tearing you in different
directions and everyone's expectation of
you how you you should be this way you
should be this way
your old stuff was the good [ __ ] and now
you're new you're new you're
you had that line your new stuff's not
the old what was it
your new shit's not as good as your old
[ __ ] too your new [ __ ] is your old [ __ ]
yeah i love that i you know as a even as
a youtube creator i get that too
i know i've seen it it's like hilarious
like you've even done videos on it like
it's it but it's what it comes down to
also is it's the time
in someone's life and it's also
relatability so when you and ella
were like [ __ ] did you guys do videos
in israel yeah
yeah so like when you're there it was
like oh my god who are these people and
then when you make the move to the
states
like you're like kind of coming up and
things are different or whatever
it's like we're coming up wow we're
watching these people we love
they're going from an apartment to a
house oh my god they're going to a house
with two bedrooms to four bedrooms oh my
god and then
you like are in a mansion and have your
own [ __ ] clothing company and you
become a millionaire and they're like
not the same man out of touch yeah
that's what we're getting out all the
time they're so
yeah they they rooting for you only to a
point you know what i mean yeah for sure
but i mean it's also like but to speak
generally because like you
pointed out there are tons of fans who
still
wish the and and support us and wish the
best for us so
it's just it's the loud minority that
always just
is like gets in your head and it's a
shame
because i think it's like uh the jungle
like if you're
on the african plane or something right
say and you walk out from the brush
only a [ __ ] idiot looks at the sky
and goes wow it's
so blue you're getting out of that brush
and you're looking for lions
immediately because that's what we are
designed to do as human beings to make
sure
that everything is okay before we can
then put you know look to the sky
so i think um like genetically like
there
you go it's in us to look at the
negative
you know on the internet or whatever
that's so [ __ ] up but it's true
it's so true i can't you know you just
can't not look at it but it's so cool
it's nice
because like it's just it sucks so bad
to give those people the attention
it does when like the good kindhearted
wholesome people that love you and want
to support you
you you you kind of look past them
because you're trying to identify the
lines in your analogy
and these people are just ah they don't
deserve your attention you know what i
mean
yeah but i think it's also what's that
what's it called imposter syndrome
like i think a lot of creative people
have that where it's like you almost
feel like a fraud
i was just gonna say that so yeah right
it's like so many times
now with teddy fresh i you know i get to
to have that feeling whenever there's
something a little like
it's uh yeah you feel like a fraud yeah
even though you're not
it's like you feel like you don't belong
you feel like oh this can't i couldn't
have done that
like literally i'm like oh what like i
went platinum what the [ __ ]
like what do you mean like what is it i
how did that even happen
um and then so in a like a sadistic way
it's almost like you're looking
to those comments to actually validate
your own insecurity or prove that you
really don't
belong there even though there's the
other side of you that wants to combat
that
and it's like for every negative comment
on the internet i always had a response
that i would
you know want to say to that person and
be like bro we'd be like best friends
like take the fact that you don't like
my raps or
how i look or this or that or whatever
the kid like take that out of it like
you i see you like cowboy bebop you like
the last of us
you like all this [ __ ] like we should be
best friends but you want to tell me to
[ __ ] kill myself
and say all the [ __ ] about me because i
don't know i wore my hat to the side or
some dumb [ __ ] like that
it's crazy but once again when you let
like i haven't been on the internet dude
in
a really long time i wanted to ask you
about that i'm jealous i'm
thinking of following in your path no
twitter
no instagram reddit you go on reddit
sometimes i sneak to reddit like every
every couple months
i'll go to reddit because it's my fans
are there and i love them and i go
you go to your subreddit yeah i go to my
subreddit yeah so i'll just go there and
just like kind of creep
because sometimes fans write really
sweet things and sometimes they write
[ __ ] up things too
and then it reminds me that's why i love
twitch i saw i did see
um on like some people were telling me
that people were trying to say
because i was i said that me going to
twitch is going to be so much better and
it's going to be the best way for me to
interact with my fans
and then all these people were like well
you looks like you've never been on
twitch before like i'm a [ __ ] idiot
like i don't know yeah
public comments exist but i'm going sub
comments
like if i go sub comments only plus mods
plus
not being able to say negative words and
all this other [ __ ]
it's funny because a lot of people would
be like oh that's like [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you have thin skin you can't take it
like who wants to be called like
you know like negative [ __ ] all day how
is that helpful to anyone's enjoyment of
the stream for people to just come in
yeah even the people who
just want to have a fun time it's going
to ruin it for them
it doesn't yeah but it's easy to say
that you know
it's so unnatural to be on the receiving
end of millions of people's
uh opinions about you because again
one of the themes of your album is like
it used to be so
easy to make wraps when you're in the
basement you have the whole world ahead
of you and
no expectations but now where you are
with people having all these
expectations of of who you should be
and so many opinions on you it's it's
just it's not the same
yeah um well first of all before i talk
about that i do want to say
i'm really happy like i am [ __ ] happy
and i'm very comfortable with myself and
i'm very comfortable in my own skin
and i think you can even notice that if
you look at these interviews i've done
recently as opposed to like anything
i've ever done before
i was always like trying to sell you
that everything was okay
and like life's great and all this [ __ ]
when it really wasn't
but the reason i'm saying this right now
is because not that we are
i just want people out there to know
sorry dude
what is wrong with me today bro this is
why people love you
just embrace it well it's a little
anyway i just want to say that like i
don't believe that this conversation
right now
is focusing on negative i think what
we're doing and i don't want it to be
perceived that way by the viewers
i think what we're doing is just talking
about [ __ ] that is
starting to now be talked about more
which i appreciate it
but because this doesn't just affect
creatives and
famous people it also affects everyday
people who do things for likes or do
things for comments or
whatever to try to get that validation
so that's the only reason i'm even like
really diving into this
regarding what you ju excuse me what you
just said you're rubbing off on me
um yes it's very difficult when
you know 10 years ago nobody gave a [ __ ]
about me and i wrote raps just to rap
like i just wrote to write and that was
it and i it was fun
and it wasn't that simple now knowing
that millions
of people you know and songs will get
billions of streams
it's a it was a scary thing on this
album
um because it's like dude everyone's
gonna
feel away and i took it all out of my
head that even though it would still
you know pop in but not being on the
internet i didn't listen to any rap
music
at all current rap music or anything
while making this album
i just went from a place of like okay
what's everything that i love because to
me this is a um
it's like a love letter to hip hop
there's so many different samples from
erica badu to outcast to
you know so many people and nods and
love and you know showing love to
kendrick and
cole and all these people um but
knowing that oh is this line good enough
like is this a good line is this even
worth it
i don't know you know i have a line um
on the song called aquarius three where
i say
i remember window shopping now i'm
shopping for windows for my baby new
room bobby coming soon
and that's the type of line i would have
second guessed putting all my [ __ ]
before
i lied about that yeah out of fear that
they would hate because they couldn't
relate because it wasn't relevant give a
[ __ ] if it's evident this right here is
the evidence i'm like leo and revenant
bear with me dog like
[ __ ] feel what i'm saying so to
piggyback on what you were saying sorry
for talking so much
um that yeah was a very difficult thing
to know that millions of people are
gonna analyze
every single thing that i do but to have
the freedom and the strength to go
[ __ ] it you know you think that having a
kid
helped you not care as much on
all that little things yeah because when
you have a child you realize like
all that matters is that my child
breathes and that my partner is happy
like that's the
like literally you know i would like
when we brought him home home from the
hospital you're like
checking under his [ __ ] thing to make
sure he's breathing that's the [ __ ] they
don't tell you
dude and it's like bro in california
okay
you have to wait like three thousand
years to like buy a firearm if you have
like a clear record and everything's
fine
they just throw a baby at you at the
hospital instead you open
yeah and like by the way there's a [ __ ]
called
uh infant death that's
syndrome did anybody tell me that
there's a thing called where
babies just [ __ ] suddenly die
i mean technically the week was so
stressful because they're too hot either
because they get too hot or they roll
over in their sleep they just [ __ ]
it's called
sudden infant death i mean there's so
many things
they turn yellow all of a sudden
jaundice yeah
did you know that babies turn yellow i
did it yeah and you put them under a
lamp
yeah you put them under a [ __ ] lamp
like a plant dude
did was your baby yellow at all uh
no he he's he was he we were very lucky
he was good and um i was very nervous
about it and scared even to this day i'm
scared i had a friend of mine
um and my brother actually we're just in
this
crazy car accident like oh no insane
like totaled car completely destroyed
and they walked out of it mind you um
yeah
they were still [ __ ] up and had to go
to the hospital i get to the scene and
there's cars smashed and on fire
and i'm looking at my brothers on a
stretcher and all this [ __ ] i'm just
like what the [ __ ] is going on
but they're okay now we were just
playing last night
but anyway um i'm always like
so i see a therapist every week and and
i love her she's
she's the bomb and she's helped me
through so much and a big thing
is also like this term called future
tripping like you know
like constantly thinking about the
future and tripping on [ __ ] that that's
really out of your control
you can't do like i used to have a
deathly fear of flying to the point
where i almost
bought a tour bus you know what i mean
on some like dj khaled [ __ ]
but i was like i gotta get through that
i was like i can't let this thing
because it's about control you know it's
about feeling like you're not in control
but you're never in control you could
have [ __ ] aneurysm right now you
could walk outside and get hit by a bus
you could
or you know you could walk outside and
meet the love of your life or
get get the dream job you always wanted
like if you're constantly thinking
negative
your life's gonna be negative if you
think more positive life will be
positive so i apply that same thought
to my son as much as i can but also
intrusive thoughts are gnarly
yeah like like having those visions of
like your baby like falling in their
head
yeah and you're like you think this like
really sick [ __ ] and you're so scared
it's normal as human
right a lot of human beings have
intrusive thoughts regardless
um but pushing my i was dealing with
intrusive thoughts for a while there and
i felt like i was like a sicko
in general um and then my my therapist
was like no those are normal
you just don't pay attention to them
exactly because the more you think about
it the more
it does and then yeah and then now i
don't even really think about [ __ ] like
that
that was the thing like when i was in
high school i developed generalizing
anxiety disorder and i feel like what it
did is just makes you hyper aware of
[ __ ] that was always happening
and you just trip about it like for
example intrusive thoughts
it was always happening but now when it
would happen
i would like like you said maybe your
baby falling out and die or just some
weird graphic thought that comes into
your mind
i start to obsess about it right or like
a song would get stuck in my head
and i would start to obsess like that
i'm [ __ ] losing my mind because i
can't get this song out of my head
stupid [ __ ] i remember when i um you
know floaters when you look like at a
blue oh yeah yeah
yeah i thought i thought i was dying
because i saw floaters bro
like that just goes to show how crazy
the ma it can get in the mind no but
that's
the power of the mind this is what i
wrote in my novel supermarket new york
times bestseller number one
um congratulations thank you so much i
you got to flex that
um but a lot of that i wrote
if you if you ever read the book it's
basically me like it's everything i was
going through i was
experiencing derealization where you
feel disconnected from reality
um yeah i was constantly like
second-guessing my own sanity i was
questioning what sanity is what it isn't
what it
and what i think that is is low-key just
like creative tax
like if you're a creative person like
that comes with it you're gonna
kind of be overstimulated mentally
you're always going to think weird [ __ ]
that you shouldn't think and this and
that but
it's like a gift and a curse if if we're
blessed as creatives
to do dope [ __ ] and make dope art
there's
some demons that kind of come with it
like dude my biggest thing
honestly and i talked about this only
excuse me recently have i talked about
this
sorry god damn [ __ ] yeah you got me
now
um i have a really
gnarly tremor right and it's like it's
called essential tremor and it's in my
hands but it's not that bad in my hands
but you see that
so if i if i yeah if i'm at rest it's
fine
um but it's all in my body right
except my dick and um your body tremors
yeah yeah so it's like it depends it's
like um
like at a certain position yes exactly
like muscles will move
basically all the time and yeah it's
this neurological disorder and it sucks
but the thing that [ __ ] with me the
most like my biggest demon nowadays
is that it's in my head so i can't
really and and i'm good at like
hiding it and it's not as bad as it
could be
because it can be degenerative and
that's what's scary
is knowing that i can really be out here
on some like [ __ ] up like shaking [ __ ]
in the future
and that really scares me and there's
options like i even try to take this
medication but it was like anti-seizure
medication and it made me feel [ __ ] up
and weird and i was like i just can't i
only took like two half doses and i
couldn't do it
but my biggest thing that scares me is
acting because i love acting and i've
been doing it recently from
mocap with video games to this dope tv
show with one of my acting idols joseph
gordon-levitt who's a
friend of mine and you know movies and
[ __ ] that i have already and i'm just
scared i'm not going to be able to
stand without my like head kind of
shaking and i know this might sound
stupid
but everybody's got problems that's what
i'm trying to say like everyone's got
something that they think about that
bothers them
and that that one's one that really
sucks but i like to be open about it
because
i mean it's kind of like the fat guy
calling himself fat before anybody else
gets
a chance to because then you just air it
out you put it in the room and then it's
like hey
okay say whatever you want now so yeah
so you say it moved up to your head
where it wasn't there before
and you mean by that just that your head
kind of tremors a little bit
yeah it was like um sometimes
i know it's not but sometimes i wonder
if it's a tick
because but i don't think it is for
example um there's a there's a yes
motion and a no motion
the thing is when i'm moving and it's
also like sensory
if i'm looking around and i'm slightly
moving my head you can't tell
but if i'm utterly still and standing up
straight my [ __ ]
goes like this literally and i can't
stop it it's like [ __ ] crazy
and there's there's a yes motion and a
no motion and the yes motion is
100 uncontrollable like if i'm trying to
like i don't know
do something i don't know like fix my
hair or something and i'm
i'm just giving you an example and i
need to be as still as possible or like
get a haircut
i can't do it because i'm so focused
it's called i think it's like
also a reaction tremor so if you're
trying to do something
uh it can [ __ ] with you anyway it's it's
kind of a boring subject
but no i'm intrigued kind of interesting
yeah oh okay well i have tourette's and
ticks too
so i am interested by it i mean
no i mean i'm i'm interested in in
what's going on
does it hurt you physically no
it's more emotionally honestly and i
know that sounds crazy but it's like
it's like this it's like somebody like
poking you because you notice it and it
rips you
i think about it a lot and my my
therapist
she's like um putting me through pain
management and i'm like yeah but there's
no pain and she goes yeah but there's
emotional pain here and if you're
constantly angry about it and upset
about it
and i didn't realize i'm actually really
really hard on myself that's another
thing in general
my my therapist she's like you need to
be nicer to yourself she's like you're
so hard on yourself and i'm like
i was like what are you talking about
you know what i mean i'm like
but it's how you say [ __ ] like for
example a lot of people do this
i do it and then now i correct myself
but i'll be like
okay here's like a stupid [ __ ] idea
right that in itself is being mean to
yourself like here's a stupid [ __ ]
idea that you're trying to downplay
so maybe it is a good idea but if if
people don't like it then it's okay
like bro here's an idea my idea is this
if somebody wants to [ __ ] on you cool
but don't [ __ ] on yourself man you know
so those are little things that
i'm learning to just be a better me and
a happier
happier me through therapy yeah i have a
similar thing where i have uh
i have tourette's and so i've got all
these facial tics and stuff and i
i assumed that i could never really act
either on in like a professional setting
just because it's so distracting
so i probably just didn't even ever try
to pursue that
but i have not noticed uh i've not
noticed the tremor but
yeah my wife she says it's more like
something that only i really notice and
most people don't notice it but
the reason that they don't notice it is
because i'm so good at hiding it
so you know like it's honestly it's why
i'm sitting in this chair
it's why i'm in this position right now
because
i enjoy because at rest
that's the one thing that makes me feel
good i don't shake
but it's when i go for that action
tremor or whatever when it when i go to
do an action then it then it starts to
shake if you look at other interviews
i've done recently where i like had to
sit on my couch and [ __ ]
i kind of move a lot and the reason i
move is because
i don't want to stay in one position or
i'll it's it's even as simple as like
placing my the tip of my finger on my
head and kind of moving it to the side
and it'll stop it
so i'm always constantly moving or doing
little things yeah but this
the crazy [ __ ] is it's like i feel like
penn teller like
i'm doing all these things that nobody
knows are being done to like
well you know do the magic of looking
like a normal human being and i'm not
people used to say that to me like they
go uh i thought you just had really
expressive eyebrows
i'm like nah i'm [ __ ] up but you know
what's funny let me ask you this too
because
some days i feel like it's better than
others and
with tourette's i've seen um
because i've seen like all your guys
videos you know and
i've noticed times where you it
basically barely never even
would happen in a video do you think
personally that it comes with stress or
is it random or
or is it the more you think about it the
more happens personally i'm curious
they said that straight sorry to
interrupt we gotta go to break
what we gotta go to break what is that a
sound bite it was a sound bad i asked
zach to use the bite
but uh but that is true we gotta go to
break let's let's
you wanna break christian dude dan just
dan does this thing where he ruins
conversations
by saying we have to go to pray huh
i don't know how i feel about getting
the sound bite on me you've told me a
million times to use it
not on me on other people no i'm kidding
what were we saying uh do you feel that
you're
you're your tics and your tourette's
death you [ __ ] there's times when it's
been i've noticed where it's almost not
even there
like yeah where were you i want to know
where were you in your life
when um you know the ticks were less
what were you feeling were you was it
even it was i'm just curious
so um they say that
that tourette's gets triggered by stress
because tourette's is a weird
condition where it can come and go in
severity
but it's it's an uncurable genetic uh
issue neurological issue and it first
manifested when i was like eight
or something like that it was super
weird i think i
i was at my uh
like grandma was getting remarried and
one of the guests there was like ticking
out like doing
this with his head and i thought it
looked cool
and i started doing it but my parent and
i that's the first time i remember
actually doing a tick but my parents say
that they noticed it before me
the thing is it runs in my family so my
mom was kind of like looking out for it
already
but when i was really young it was super
bad like
my parents took this home video of me in
elementary school when i was supposed to
be standing up straight
as davy crockett i had like a musket
and i was doing this whole david
crockett speech but i was i was like
twitching out so
[ __ ] crazy i've gone back and watched
that home video i don't remember it
being that bad but it was brutal
do you feel it when it happens so the
thing is that
it's not involuntary with tourette's
it's like you have an itch yeah
and you have the this overwhelming
burning
need to do this thing so like if
i'm sitting in a room i can not tick but
it's like ignoring this really brutal
uh desire to itch yourself scratch okay
wait hold on right now okay just
just just try not to do it
just stay don't even talk i just want to
see how long
yeah i can i mean you just did it
oh i did yeah i didn't notice i think
it's cool though like no it's
not gonna be like yeah this [ __ ]
thing that plagues you is cool but it's
like
i think it's dope i i think you're like
an advocate for it
i think you're a very successful person
um
i think you have a partner who's who's
there for you and understand and it lets
people know like dude like dude not only
do
you live a normal life you live an
extraordinary life with this thing that
a lot of people
are self-conscious about and honestly as
i'm saying this it makes me feel better
about myself like that's what you're
doing
so keep thank you you know i'm very
fortunate because
i have a mild case some people have it
really really really
but you do go through phases where
sometimes it will get worse and uh yeah
or you you'll have certain tics that
even hurt you
and you're like my neck just hurts all
the time
i used to get headaches all the time
because i would shake my head like
really violently
or you throw it when you have like the
yeah vocal
but the one well so but still that's a
mild right because
with people who have really bad
tourettes they're just screaming out
obscenities and that's a really rare
form of tourette's only like two percent
of people have it where they just like
scream like they curse they have this
desire to like curse and stuff
but tourette's is characterized by
having vocal tics as opposed to ocd or
something like that so
i'm always clearing my throat and going
like stuff like
some people may notice that i do that
but um
i was really fortunate growing up to
have like an unusually kind
and supportive group of friends who
didn't goof on me for it
that's dope because i feel like you
could easily get
[ __ ] by a bunch of ruthless kids
you know and my friends were just
unusually
accepting i have to say looking back on
it
um they would go why are you doing that
and i'm like i have this thing called
tourette's and they'd be like oh cool
and then they would never bring it up
again
yeah that's pretty awesome i was like
what yeah looking back i'm like
wow though that is extraordinary
so i've been i've been fortunate you
know in that regard
my biggest thing wait do we have to take
a break or something okay let's take a
break it enough but it's not it's not a
real way
yeah we can just say we're just gonna be
like okay we're cutting
and then i'm gonna do the add later so
here
break
this may not look like much to you and
stature
but what this little block of
indestructible metal is
is a wallet for the new world
ridge wallet revolutionizing the wallet
as we know it no longer do we need to
walk around with giant costanzo wallace
that frankly give you back problems
that uh mess your posture up when you
sit down on them
it's it's just out of date what do we
need change for what do we need all this
crap for
the ridge wallet money clip boom
credit cards up to like 11 fit perfectly
in there and slide right out
i use this but i always show my credit
card number
so everybody prohibits me from showing
my actual one in my wallet
it's indestructible you buy it once you
own it for life
i'll tell you what this metal that it's
made of actually prevents
uh digital thieves there's people that
scan your [ __ ] when they walk by you
they can't do that in this and they've
got all these beautiful
um models too look at you that one's
sick it's got a nice
rose gold it's like metallic oh it's
rose gold i mean i'm just saying i don't
know if that's what it's called but it's
got like a metallic rose finish yeah
it's real nice ridge wallet
i mean i don't know what to say it's a
great wallet we all love it we all
started we got
all got on the ridge train and uh
we haven't looked back right zach i love
rage
amazing product could not be happier
with it
and you're not just saying that are you
absolutely not it's a game changer
absolutely how can they tell if you're
just saying that or because
you really love it i really love this
product yeah but how can they tell
you're not lying zach
i i i can't express you enough how much
i love this product
no but say it so they do they believe
you no i'm just kidding
zach does use it all the time there's
over 30 colors and styles actually i
want to pull it up because they're
really cool
ridge dot com slash h3
that's right rich dot com slash a tree
look at all these beautiful colors
ooh
titanium like i like my uh why is there
a little zap
corner i got a little baby zach oh he's
small
why can you not see does it matter it
doesn't really matter he's just there
yeah i like seeing zach makes me feel
comfortable oh thank you
camo uh aluminum yeah tiki
pink it's rose gold you're right it is
yeah nice let me tell you about ridge
they've got thirty thousand five star
reviews it's durable
and lasts for a lifetime ridge team is
so confident that you'll like it you can
test drive it for 45 days
and if you don't love it you can send it
back for a full refund
wow here is the deal as well
you can get 10 percent off right now
with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com h3 that's ridge.com
h3 and use code h3
hey ho ho ho ho hey we're back
so just to end this with the one thing
that
really freaks me out talk shows
because of this thing right it's like
and that's
sorry that's my in-laws dogs they're
staying with us oh um
yeah talk shows man like i for me it's
where you feel like you can't
relax or that you have to stand a
certain way or look a certain way and
then i'm like oh my god i'm gonna like
shake or freak out or whatever
that's it but i mean at the end of the
day dude [ __ ] it
i feel like you should just uh let it
shake
just shake and bake shake it up i mean
look at uh who was it
was it um was it liza minnelli
i think so right am i tripping does she
have a shake
no liza minnelli's mom who's liza
manelli's mom
who's the chick from wizard of oz beauty
garland judy garland
yes she had essential tremor oh so there
you go so that's why she was like that
yeah i guess
anyway i think the thing to do is just
instead of feeling nervous and trying to
hide it just [ __ ] let it
just let it hang out and you know it is
what it is right
i mean the thing about my tourette's is
i could easily be like oh i'm never
going to get in front of a camera
because i look like a freak
and uh i think people embrace it because
i embrace it
i agree i think i'm comfortable
with it that's why i talk about it but i
it's still
it still personally ails me so that's
why i try to do the things that i can do
where it doesn't shake because i haven't
reached a point where
um because it like i said it feels like
someone's poking me
it feels like i i notice it rips me from
the moment
my son yeah yeah i see i've had that
happen before like very rarely
i'll feel like someone poked my neck and
i'm like you know like that yeah
well no i mean like it's i would like
metaphorically poking me like
so it takes you out of the moment though
yeah yeah because
like i'll be talking to my son or or i
mean playing with my son or talking to
my wife
and then i'll just like my head will
start going like this and then i realize
it and i'm like what the [ __ ]
and then everything we just talked about
yeah
it's like that but it's not that deep
anyway it is that deep dude
there you go yes so um
how good are you at swaddling
i'm a swaddle master yeah i thought it
would be i'm pretty good at a swaddle
too
i was pretty good with swaddle man i i
did a good job
um for those of you out there who don't
know what we're talking about
uh swaddling is when you basically take
like a
like a fat like a like a little blanket
for a baby
and you um make them all nice and tight
burrito
yeah you put it yeah you make them a
little burrito awesome and it's
literally like doing a burrito you flip
it over
you were really good at it i never got
good at it somehow yeah
same with britney britney was cool my
wife she was all right but
dude our well our nurse is like the
[ __ ]
mask yeah of the swaddles it's like it
couldn't be
out of it yeah there's like a straight
jacket
so i was living in her shadow but doing
my best
and i was just texting her because i
told her to come say hello she's like
i'm shy
is it on the podcast and i'm like
[ __ ] so it's all good yeah i'd love
to see them
yeah i don't know where bobby is because
we um
we have his his aunt who's gonna start
helping us take care of him
a few days a week so that way um you
know my wife can because she paints now
which is really amazing she's a really
good artist actually
and just to have that time because she's
21 too dude like she's so young and
and the thing is she was very much so
like
like she didn't want help she didn't
want she wanted to do everything herself
which i get and she's like an amazing
mom but
um i kind of was like yo like you
deserve to have a life
you know what i mean like it's okay
you're still a great mom go
do some [ __ ] you know whether it's like
horseback riding and painting or
just enjoying it like you deserve that
throughout the week go do it
so first at first i feel like we kind of
i totally get that because at first
especially on your first kid
it's just you don't understand what's
going on yeah and you just want to be
there and experience the whole thing
yeah yeah but now i don't even see
theodore i'm kidding everyone should be
like this is the worst dad
out of touch i know it's funny
though also how people will just take an
obvious joke and really
try to like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so um
why so you're out of la escape from la
what was the name of that movie saw uh
escape from escape from l.a miller you
got it
well what was the franchise from new
york was the first one
yeah but what was the name what was the
franchise just the
escape frame they just escaped yeah [ __ ]
that was a bad escape saga
yeah yeah so how has escape from la been
for you
it's been great because i was never
really an la guy and i didn't realize
that until
like 10 years of being in l.a you had
just recent
or recently-ish moved to the house
where we last saw you yeah two years and
you were
20 2018 yeah you were doing a lot of
work on that house did it was it a
bummer to like
do all that work and then bounce wow
that's a great question so
for those of you out there who don't
know what he's referring to exactly i
built this
crazy theater for like 300 grand and
then
i built a a home studio for a million
dollars
whoa yeah that was a nice studio oh my
gosh i loved it yeah it's really amazing
um
but where i am now is like way better
um and i love it and it is a little sad
that i don't have that
but i think there's i'm just gonna like
i don't know either build a studio or
buy one or
but i also don't need it like i'm still
always gonna make music even though i'm
retired like i love making
i love music like whether it's rap music
or any kind
so i'm still going to do that and
somehow you know i don't know i might
just like andre 3000 it and like every
once in a while like drop a random song
or do a feature or something like that
because as far as albums and [ __ ] i'm
done with that
yeah did you you sold did you sell your
house in l.a
not yet i'm just fixing a few little
things and then and then i'll
and then i'll put it up yeah i was
wondering if you got like
i wonder if you're getting gonna get
your investment pack or you don't care
you just want to get it
i don't really care but i think i'll be
able to i'm definitely gonna make money
on it for sure because i improved it so
much
and whoever's gonna buy it is definitely
gonna be an entertainer either film or
music because of the studio and i'm just
going to buy a studio
yeah crazy studio so it's going to be
worth it to that person so
yeah yeah it won't be like a loss or
anything but where you moved
it's got to be the real estate uh
cost it's got to be way way way way way
less right
yeah dude i bought so my house that i'm
in now is
four stories four levels and it's
literally four times the size
that that you guys saw that's crazy oh
my god it's crazy and it and it was for
like a million dollars
less than i bought the other house for
dude it's crazy when you just step
outside like
new york or los angeles or these kind of
cities and
it's did it blow your mind what you
could get for that price
yeah dude yeah you get so desensitized
come here here we go come here come on
here come neil right here say hello
hey hey how are you guys
how are you good how are you good
congrats on being a new parent i'm very
camera shy
yeah can you hear them oh can you hear
it yeah
how was uh how was how's being on mom
it's amazing it's hard
it's hard it's very hard dude the first
six months
because we're in like year 1.3 now the
first six months is the most brutal for
sure
it's really tough it's stressful yeah
but i think
now we're getting our routine down we're
like creating a schedule
yeah we have help help has been like my
mom
grandma has been a huge help help i
wouldn't have been able to do it without
her for sure
but i mean i would have but it would
have been difficult
yeah yeah she's the bomb through the
night
oh yeah baby sleeps through the night oh
that's good
yeah yeah we got a night nurse that
helped us sleep yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you gotta get the knife good
are you nervous yeah i'm very camera shy
can i keep talking to you or do you want
to leave well oh i'm
i'm okay okay we're just talking as long
as you're comfortable no i'm okay
we're very our privacy is very important
i love how i'm like
come beyond this huge podcast with me
yeah yeah yeah well our privacy is
important but we're buddies so it's a
little different
well
how was the birth
it was it's really cool to look back on
yeah because now i know this sounds
weird but now i know my pain
did tolerance do the epidemic yeah like
it was i basically went all the way
without i got the epidural like last
time okay literally like she got the
epidural and then 15 minutes later
oh my god really no i'm so glad i got it
when i did because then i
would have been doing it naturally but
yeah
yeah i know it's really cool to look
back on and i love telling the story to
friends and stuff
yeah because they're always like i can't
believe you gave i have
a audio journal that i've been doing for
like really giant moments in my life and
i started with that my buddy guy
roz um he's uh
he's got a podcast called how i built
this and he
basically was like yeah you should
create audio journals where
you just record like these these moments
as they happen
like like right after they happen and
then you'll have every single detail
and that's one of them like i saw them
like copper water and [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] gnarly
oh yeah like a few days after right
because you were like we have to
remember this yeah it was like three
days but to me it was like really
beautiful i know like a lot of people
honestly like certain guys i know are
like nah man you don't want to see that
[ __ ] dog and you don't wanna it
made me even more attracted to my wife
personally seeing like
that and everything that happened i
loved it i thought it was i thought it
was crazy
it was really funny though because my
back was hurting
we have to talk about how i [ __ ] my
back up was he complaining about his
back hurting
yeah she's in bed and i'm like have no
idea the pain
i was obviously joking when i was having
like the
worst contractions getting a needle
stuck in my back
he's like my back hurts like i was doing
it to make her be like hey
be like hey can i get some of that
epidural yeah one thing that was really
cool is uh for the show i told you about
my buddy joe
um i was going over my lines and i had
been going because like whenever i do
something especially acting i just go
all in and i make it like that's the
biggest focus
um obviously besides my wife giving
birth um but while she was there in bed
we were like doing our lines back and
forth together
do you regret not getting the epidural
earlier are you happy that you got it
right up at the end
i'm happy i did it at the end i
definitely
could have gotten it earlier but
it was a pretty intense pain right
before
so like i said i'm glad i did it when i
did because then
now i know i can go through that amount
of pain and it's pretty cool yeah
now i'm prepared for next baby but but
she has a good time how i felt
too i felt like i my i feel like my
whole life i had a fear
of giving birth like it just seemed to
me like the worst thing possible
yeah and um it just like yeah it's
painful but
it's fine like you can make it through
it yeah definitely looking back at it
it's like
wasn't terrible yeah yeah i could do
that [ __ ]
i i don't want to do yeah i'm doing oh
my god you
would die yeah no i would die i don't
try to hide it i [ __ ] care i wouldn't
it's easy for me but like yeah i would
be terrified to do that
well i don't know like when ila gave
birth i was holding her leg
like what was your point of view bobby i
was holding her leg
and uh looking so you saw the whole
thing yeah
i was [ __ ] there for everything dog i
saw a little alien pop out of there
yeah it's really gnarly too is i you
imagine that it's this like cute little
flesh-colored thing
inside but it's not it's all white it
looks like [ __ ] voldemort
and then it comes out and then it
breathes and then it looks like barney
and it's all like blue oh all red
purple and red and stuff i just remember
i remember him coming out and his the
top of his dome just looked like a
meatball
like all white and bumpy it was crazy i
did one of those like
like when the baby actually came out one
of those oh
because they took him out and then they
they immediately
bring them over to some table table
to like clean them off and inspect them
and make sure he's breathing and stuff
and you're like
go be with him yeah because i was like
uh
yeah i didn't know what to do it's like
did you cut the cord weirdo
doctors are immediately all around him
and i was like go
go be with him yeah but anyway he held
on to my fingers it was dope
that's a vibe yeah birth birth was a
gnarly experience
and i got to pull him out too he did
watch me
yeah like he after his head and his
shoulders were out
oh oh my gosh
that must have been so weird yeah it was
crazy my doctor told me to do that and
when
she said that i was like what are you
talking about no you do it yeah for him
reach for him and i'm like
okay what was that like oh my god
what did that i mean what did that feel
what was that like for you
well grabbing him obviously like feeling
him it was just like a big slime ball
yeah yeah yeah yeah sounds so gross no
no it was crazy because it was my first
time just touching him was
weird because i'm just touching my belly
for nine months
saying i'm touching him but then i
actually touch him
and it's like that's where is he where
is he
he's sleeping oh don't wake his ass up
yeah it was the crazy thing was first of
all ela's water didn't break until
she was giving birth so there was like a
crazy water break moment
and then um did you see the
what was it called the placenta come out
i didn't see it
oh my god we didn't we didn't see it i
wish we got to see it i saw it it was
the wildest [ __ ]
really like alien stuff they just take
the umbilical cord
and yank this organ out of her
this is crazy and they just remember
feeling it though i remember
yeah i remember feeling it too okay now
you're giving birth to the placenta
how long did you guys wait to [ __ ] do
it again
oh oh we did it like two weeks after do
it again oh well ela so ela had like a
hair
she got her vag torah
sorry we had to do some stitching and
it took a couple it took a little longer
i think than
it should have i don't know i actually
don't know they made it sound like i had
just like one little tear but then she
was stitching me for like an hour
dude so i don't really know yeah that
yeah theodore got you good on the way
out
okay yeah but so actually i don't
remember because eli
healed kind of slow because of that yeah
yeah two weeks
wow there you go yeah we weren't
supposed to but we did it anyway
then like we're at what did they tell
you like a month yeah they were like
wait a month
and then we went supposed to wait six
weeks oh six weeks and then we were in
the um
in the doctor's office and i was sitting
there and the doctors talking
and i was just like we had sex is it
okay
she was like oh yes
anyway all right give me a kiss are you
guys are you guys planning another one
what's going on
we said we said that we wanted to
have another one really quick but we
kind of think we want to chill for a
little bit
yeah enjoy it we're liking the only
child
vibe right now but i mean we'll have
another one yeah we're still practicing
a lot yeah you'll feel it okay that's
good yeah
i love you you're beautiful
so it's got that big old white girl
booty
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right what's up um
you know what's weird really quick are
you are you taking contraceptive
if you're not trying to have a kid no
she's she wants to get like an iud or
whatever
which kind of freaks me out because i'm
like what if there's like a problem with
it
for a while yeah it does last for a
while no
we're just you know well we we don't use
contraceptives
and it's in god's hands you know what i
mean every time
well now since since theodore was born
yeah
wow that's crazy because we kind of just
go by that like first couple days
after the period well but the thing is
that
um i think because of her age
you know what i mean she probably would
get pregnant a lot [ __ ]
easier than ela that's true i'm i think
i'm
much older right like she's 21 yeah how
old are you
32 32. because the thing is when
when you're that age you just breathe on
someone and they get pregnant
true that's how it happened i was like
hey
yeah and then it happened um yo
ela so you're you're you're um
our favorite of the h3s
are you guys i'm kidding but no but
seriously we love you and uh
i should have talked about this while my
wife was here
bro we re-watch the videos all the time
for your reaction
because i feel like i feel like ethan is
the best
commentator but the way you react to
[ __ ]
is hilarious or wait maybe it's the
opposite what i mean is like
no yeah you know you dude the fine bros
bro
like i'll never forget when we do this
all the time eli was like i mean we
already have
an n-word do you know what i'm talking
about wait what was it about
when they were like you can't say nazis
they're like oh you can't be throwing
that word out there when we're doing the
seinfeld reaction
yeah right and i was like
yeah because because i'm not sure if
what i'm saying is like funny
or not or if i shouldn't say it so i'm
always like
yeah so i said it like i wasn't sure if
i should say it
because i was like there's already an
animal yeah right i remember that
line but i don't remember the video i
forget the [ __ ] we've made it is it the
one where they make fun of seinfeld
yeah it's ridiculous that's my favorite
that's the number one thing there's like
shows that shouldn't that wouldn't be
okay today
we made a video about that yeah bro are
you kidding it's like one of the best
ones
well i could see myself wanting to make
a video about that because i'm very
defensive about seinfeld i don't have
any tolerance for people that say they
don't like seinfeld
i don't i just don't accept that i don't
get it either it's like
yeah how do you not like curb you know
what i mean like what what are you
talking about
these are everyday clearly this is
that's it's why i love the reason i love
seinfeld
is because if you really notice i mean
it's so
genius everything they don't there's no
like
cell phone or this or like it's not
things aren't like based on
current [ __ ] it's um to me it's like i
watch it and it's
something that could easily happen today
i
yeah no the guy was like you can't be
throwing that word around these days
and you just destroyed him you were like
what what do you mean
you were like you were like there's uh
they're new york city jews can't say the
word nazi
it was crazy and i'm like dude like
you're right
i didn't know that that was so funny i
didn't know that that was a thing it
really came as
i didn't know it i don't think it is by
the way the soup nazi
yeah watch seinfeld i mean come on so
yeah we honestly we like
we love watching your videos you know we
check every day
wow before we go to bed to see if
there's a new um
if there's a new video on youtube
there's not i know
i'll ruin the surprise i know it's
demanding though i get it
well for me it was just really hard to
find content to make for the main for
the h3h3 productions channel
and i didn't want to just force it and
like ultimately when you
when you just force it there are some
people on youtube who do commentary that
are really wholesome and nice
like um drew there's these guys drew
goodman and danny gonzalez that make
really good wholesome
commentary content that i like um
and gus as well but for me i just didn't
want to fall into this pit of becoming
the cynical [ __ ] [ __ ] that just
shits on everybody
but that's awesome like yeah but it
could be a point
i don't know yeah but it's not for me
it's not like
you're really that i don't think you're
that i think you're i think you're the
voice in everyone's head who like
watches the bachelor or something like
do you know what i mean like you're the
guy but it's funny it's like
it's it's joke but so i don't i don't i
guess i don't like clowning on people
that don't deserve it or
who i feel don't deserve obviously
that's subjective and i think a lot of
of like a lot of my early career was
making fun of these pranks and [ __ ] and
these
obvious like scumbag low-life [ __ ] that
just deserved to be said the worst
things about so that made it really easy
to do my job in that sense
so then was it hard to do skippy because
he's just like so adorable and sweet
hippies
yeah you know exactly but well skippy
was okay
because i feel like it wasn't a mean
spirited video and it was really
kind of funny subject matter but it's
more about like
maybe youtubers who everybody's [ __ ]
on and i just don't want to make a video
about them
no i don't think that i think like
reactionary videos like i've i've seen
your subreddit when i'd gone on
when i first discovered you and a few
years ago
and there was a lot of well after i met
you guys
i don't think anybody even knows how we
met we should get into that but
um a lot of your fans actually really
have great
ideas of stuff that you can commentate
on that are even just as funny as like
old 80s infomercials that are like
really weird and like low-key
white supremacist [ __ ] on tv like you
know what i mean like yeah
well yeah it's it's just another problem
was that it's so hard to know if
if it is good or not and then i'll shoot
the video and then be like oh this
sucks and it's just so demoralizing i
don't know
it's tough i think you're i think you're
funny and i also
don't think you should ever force it and
you should do what you want when you
want how you want and it doesn't matter
what iron
it kind of got to like just an overall
negative thing
where the process wasn't fun for us and
then also there was
a lot of criticism kind of like
what you were feeling i guess and yeah
how you described that you just
were done with it you just totally don't
want to make another album
yeah we just kind of got to that point
with those videos
yeah but you've also given people
literally years and years and years of
that
plus variety in your videos you don't
owe nobody [ __ ] that's the funny thing i
think is
yes we are servants
as far as and being entertainers like we
do owe
something to the people but like to an
extent you know what i mean like
if you're not happy doing it then don't
do it that's why how i feel about music
like making music
um for
cons like cons like mainstream
consumption and [ __ ] like that does not
appeal me i've been going back and forth
if i should drop this free mixtape
where it's just me rapping on a bunch of
like famous beats that i love like we
used to do back in the day
that excites me that makes me so excited
to be like
no no one is in their right mind would
even like review this
and if they do like cool whatever it
doesn't matter but it's not
on spotify it's not here it's not there
it's going to be some [ __ ]
dropbox link that i would like tweet out
like that's that's awesome
i like the idea of free music yeah i
love the idea of just a dropbox link
yeah it's not even on youtube or some
[ __ ] you know you guys remember how we
met
yeah i didn't mean to interrupt you
right yeah justin's house that was
really funny
because so justin he was telling me
i didn't know about your music and then
justin was telling me that you were in
rick and morty
and he was telling me about your music
and that's how i discovered you
and then um it was at his birthday party
or something
and i s and then and then i recognized
you i don't remember
there was also another well we we got it
from two angles that was one and then
mac was the other one where oh yeah we
went
we went to one about that we went
through demarco
what you didn't know about yeah exactly
i cause we're friends with mac
and he's like yo i'm going to this dude
logic's concert we saw you at the greek
oh yeah and then he got he got [ __ ]
faced uh no he told me that night
because he was gonna come hang out at my
house afterwards
because we were in la and he was like
sorry man i puked all over my driveway
oh my god i guess i left before that
it was awesome so we went it was really
fun because we went and we were just
having a good time and uh you were
playing mario kart and [ __ ]
right yeah yeah yeah on stage i actually
went i i went
36-0 on that whole tour we did like 36
shows
and every night i invited either a fan
or uh
you know a stagehand somebody who who's
working on the show backstage
i [ __ ] won every game it's pretty
good man
you might be ready for the pro circuit
yeah totally
but i think when we came to the show we
never actually got to see you
and then i think that was i think that
happened first and then we saw you at
justin's house
right and i was like yeah you're like
who are you
oh really that's when how it happened oh
yeah you're right yep
100 because i was actually
single then because i had just separated
from my previous wife and then i was
there and uh
yeah that was crazy that was like one of
the first times i would like i had just
kind of been out alone
oh it was nice to be around people yeah
it was pretty cool but you guys for sure
were really sweet and i just remember
being like who the [ __ ] are these people
like they're so nice and then i yeah and
i thought you guys like
were just really cool and then i go home
yeah no for real i thought you were so
cool and then i go home and then i'm
like
oh my god this is amazing and i just
like to do is watch your videos
like that's so funny well you make me
want to make videos again
yes i want you know it's like it's so
nice to know that people watch and
enjoy it because like i feel
i feel i can relate very much to your uh
your struggles as a creative because i
feel like we eq
we get a lot of there's so much
expectations on the old me and that knew
me and people want me to do it this way
and that way and yeah this video is not
funny and that video is funny
i saw this comment we made this video on
uh
the it was on the something virgin
what was it oh that's skippy
yeah so they go someone commented like
oh the
good old golden years which i found so
funny because when we were making that
video people were already [ __ ] on me
for having changed
and saying they missed our old videos
bro when i released my first album
it was this sucks this is terrible
you sound like kendrick and drake and j
cole and this and that
this is not as good as your mixtapes and
then i released
my second album and people were like
this is [ __ ] garbage you did a whole
album about space this is nerd [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] about this you have
no place in hip-hop
this is worse than your debut album then
i did my third
album and 1 800 was on it oh you sold
out this is garbage
and then you fast forward now and people
are like yo your first and second album
yeah and i'm just like
and you're like i wanted to die the
whole time yeah yeah exactly so it's
funny because like
you're doing those things thinking
you're not good enough and you're like
trying to impress it's like really funny
but when it comes to videos too dude
like i'm sitting on so much music
like i'm sitting on i mean i have 10 000
plus songs right
but those are i i would say
jordan or lebron shooting in the gym
like you
there weren't cameras there you know
there's a [ __ ] ton of misses
there's also some really go good gold
there um
but even now like the new music like i
haven't actually written a song in a
long time
um but i will i have this whole mixtape
basically that i'm sitting on and i want
to i want to finish it for fun
and i just say this to say that it's
kind of almost view it like that where
if you do want to make videos don't
don't
second-guess yourselves you guys are
really really really funny
and at the end of the day it's like the
last of us like
i remember there was that whole everyone
was like pissed off about the game do
you remember that
no so there's this video game called
last of us and very long story short
it's
i love it i [ __ ] love it and i
thought it was amazing
and people could be like oh well because
i'm in the game i'm in the video game
but like that's not why i like it if it
was garbage
i'd be like yo this sucks thanks for the
check you know what i mean but like
so i'm not biased in that sense i'm
it holds a place in my heart for sure
but i just say all this to say like
there were people who were like [ __ ]
on that game before it even came out
and then still spent 60 dollars to play
the game
anyway and it's like these people who
say
things about you me any anything when it
comes to art
they just they love you they are
obsessed with you you know what i mean
and so for somebody to
say these things you shouldn't let it
affect
how you create and it's funny because
only one stepping away
and really being like [ __ ] y'all i'm out
of here did i personally realize that so
i say that to say
that if you guys ever just woke up one
day and was like yo let's find some
really funny [ __ ] and react to it
um and you did that you also don't have
to put it out
you could sit there and save it you
could [ __ ] do 20 videos just because
you love it because it's a
sunday afternoon and you have two hours
free or whatever you know what i mean
and you just kind of have a good time
and just enjoy it
and then if you ever want to release it
you kind of have that in the in the bag
so
just do it for fun i will say though
like
what you perceive as negative personally
if it is negative if you sit there and
go oh
these videos we're making are like mean
okay cool if that's how you feel about
it
i personally never saw it that way i
almost saw it like a real life
fontano needle drop about like
funny [ __ ] like you know this chick's in
l in love with an amusement park what
the [ __ ] is that like that is hilarious
that's
really really funny and i think yeah if
you focused on that unless
like you said any drama or youtube [ __ ]
like [ __ ] that even though
not to get into it i don't want to get
into it that keemstar [ __ ] was hilarious
i thought it was funny i thought it was
hilarious yeah anyways super fun
what you love just do what you love man
[ __ ] all the life is so
short like i think it really is i do
fantasize about like
sometimes i i swing back and forth i
fantasize about coming back and making
a bunch of videos on h3 but then i just
always hate it when i try
why because it's exhausting
in what sense the actual work or more so
trying to please
this fictional person in your head that
is the viewer
before they even see it i think i'm just
always disappointed for the most part
by why by the process and everything
but why
um let's talk it out no rush
i think i put so much the thing on
youtube is like
it's people really uh put a lot of
content out
and that's like a way to succeed on
youtube the thing is i
we tend to put a lot of work into our
videos but
it doesn't necessarily show and so
i'll just put a video out and a lot of
times i'm not happy with it and i just
see all the
negativity and then the video doesn't do
as well as i hoped and
i'm just like oh [ __ ] off but none of
that has to do with the art and it's the
same thing i was going through like i
there was a time where i was looking at
like travis scott
and like a j cole like how many likes do
they have on a post and
this and that and all this other [ __ ]
and it's like why am i looking at these
other people that i [ __ ] with and
respect and i'm comparing myself
to them you know and when you're
thinking about like numbers like oh okay
this song's out oh but it only has 20
million plays in a week or
oh man like what the what what 20
million plays or this
none of that [ __ ] it it's all [ __ ]
dude
like you have been conditioned and
trained
into believing that that's what matters
and the funny thing is
there's a par a part of in time in your
careers
and mine where it did matter you needed
to
to like put the asses in the seats sell
the tickets do the numbers
in order to be successful but you guys
are already successful
you went from the young up-and-coming
funny little secret just like i did
to this gigantic company a walking
[ __ ] brand
and because of that there's all this
pressure that you still have to be as
good as the [ __ ] kid who plays
minecraft and gets like 50 million views
and one thing
like nah like you're in a completely
separate thing and at the end of the day
you should only be doing it for the love
and that's why now
when i if if there's a i do twitch or if
i post something on instagram or this or
that
bro you don't even want to know the
level of
separation the six degrees of separation
tell me that i've created
so if you want to post on instagram what
happened if i want to post on instagram
there is an email thread with seven
people on it
i'm not even joking everyone has a job
and they double check spelling the
caption
do you want it on the main instagram do
you want it on your story do you also
want it on twitter
should we post this on facebook whatever
the case may be
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] right i'm
like just post the [ __ ] like i don't
care
and then i'm like don't tell don't i
don't want to see comments don't talk to
me about comments don't this don't that
none of that [ __ ] i just want to know
that i'm at least giving my fans
something because i appreciate them and
i love them so
i don't know here's me eating spaghetti
or something it's just like like
enjoy this now there's that but [ __ ]
twitch
i don't i barely sometimes i look in in
the chat
because it is positive it's really not
that yeah when you're on sub only it's
pretty good
yeah but it's also on uh like the slow
where you can't
type but even that it's like so what i
have to do is i my buddy justin he's
right next to me right now and he'll go
through my twitter
and he'll go through the the sub chat
and screenshot and send those shots to
my phone where i don't have
uh instagram twitter reddit anything
nothing is there
and he'll personally send me those and
then i have to go through
and select which ones that i want to see
so this also is like i don't have to
hear
things like oh you're a blah blah blah
and all these like mean
spirited things that people will can say
especially on twitter
and the reason i love this is because it
kind of encapsulates
positivity in the sense of if i'm not
seeing
the negativity it's not going to affect
me
and all i can do is is be happy
when giving that content to the fans so
it's really crazy to think about that
though because when i first started it's
like
i was able to literally just be on my
phone and talk
to people and have a conversation yeah
and now when you have people
like i like towards the end of the why i
got off social media it's because i
would talk to a fan and be like hey i
love you so much
and then somebody would like drop the f
word whatever the [ __ ] you know what i
mean just like say these really
mean things i mean i i used to tweet out
every day not that i
it's not like i don't do this because of
that i just now people know but like
peace love and positivity that's
literally my slogan that's my thing
and i would have so many people comment
back war hate and negativity
what and they say that yeah gnarly i
just said it
yeah i wouldn't be surprised though
um has your perspective changed along
the whole
uh love peace positivity
because it used to be like i think like
you were touching on
there was a kind of an aspect of forced
positivity
when you were in front of a camera or
when you were talking about yourself
pretending like things were all good do
you think that your perspective on that
has changed at all
no i'm still a big advocate i think
i think i just wanted to be a driving
force to do everything that i could to
put that out there even on my own dark
days
you know what i mean so it never felt
fake or
uh like it wasn't from the heart it
always was and i think that's why when i
was
down you know in the gutter or going
through what i was going through
personally i pushed it even more because
i knew that if i needed to hear that
someone else out there needed to hear it
so i would i would really push that
not that i don't anymore i totally do
it's like my thing but i kind of like
it's like biracial like we get it like i
mean like everyone knows who i am like
they know my thing so it's not that deep
like um
but yeah that was that was hard dude
like
the hardest my life has ever been was
when i was rich and famous
and this is a from a kid who was broke
on hoc welfare food stamps parents on
drugs
you know i've been kidnapped uh
physically beaten
um yeah it's just the gnarlyish gnarly
that said it again
the gnarliest [ __ ] has happened to me in
my life
and it does not compare to what i went
through
as a as a famous wealthy person which is
so stupid
um but it's crazy actually
i think it was more isolated i was able
to deal with it i never
questioned my race or who i was
everybody knew who i was you know what i
mean
it's like you said with your tick like
oh yeah i have tourette's everyone's
like cool they're
you know they're like oh what's up white
boy and i'm like oh no this is my dad
and they're like oh you're a brother
okay cool that's
it like that was it was it wasn't a
thing you know
um which is which is pretty crazy i'm
writing my autobiography right now
oh wow yeah it's [ __ ] insane dude
like the things that would be
interesting yeah yeah yeah
would you say i said that would be an
interesting read for sure oh man yeah
i'll send you guys i'll send it to you
um early but it's like i'm in it i'm in
the thick of it i'm still in my
childhood and we've been working on it
for like six months
so and yeah i know it's it's insane
and i and that you want to talk about uh
imposter syndrome like
i read this and i'm like there's no way
i was cooking crack as a teenager on a
stove what are you talking about you
know what i mean i'm like there's no way
i was holding guns
and pounds of marijuana at 11 years old
in tacoma park in southeast dc
in the [ __ ] hood running from the
police
no way and then i'm like yeah i mean
i i've never i've never uh i don't
you know my life is not fallacy you know
it's just i've always been honest and
and that's what's that's actually really
weird
thinking about that [ __ ] like i can't
believe it i literally can't believe
you look at me you know i got my glasses
and peace love and all this yeah you
definitely i don't you don't strike me
as a crack dealer
but i do think that i never dealt the
crack that was my
the crap okay but i did cook you're the
chef
i'm the i'm the rayquan baby so
i do think it's interesting though
because you s you strike
you strike me as a very wholesome kind
of guy and
i think it's an interesting statement on
just being the victim of circumstance
and doing
[ __ ] to survive but like you know
i think people tend to look at people
like that as just bad people
but it but i think when you separate
someone from the circumstance
of the birth and this need to fight to
survive
you can really see people like i see you
as so much different than
how i would have seen you as a person
back then
yeah it's funny um drake just came out
with this song
um forget what the [ __ ] it's called i
think a little dirk's on it
now cry later yeah god damn turn your
mic down
again but uh
yeah yeah it sounds like the voice of
god
uh but yeah drake has some line on it
about never being embraced
i was like damn like if he feels still
like he's not embraced by hip-hop and
he's like
that's true drake is a lot of [ __ ] i
mean it's true he does
he he does and and the funny thing is is
when i look at my
life you know surrounded by drugs
parents addicted to drugs you know
seeing gang violence and prostitution
and you know police all the time
eviction letters being homeless it's
like i am the poster child
for the underdog that made it you know
what i mean and yet
i think based on how i carry myself how
i speak the things i'm interested in
like
manga and [ __ ] sci-fi and all this
other [ __ ]
that's a big part of why i wasn't
accepted
but like who is accepted like the
[ __ ] on the block shooting the
tech nine talking about i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill the baby in this [ __ ]
stomach and a drive-by and
like you know what i mean like you know
okay like what is that
what is that you know like it's not
about
i think that negativity and that's when
i realized stepping away from hip-hop
that i had always been accepted by
hip-hop for sure i mean i have songs
with wu-tang clan and
i'm texting eric about do and i'm
talking to the rizza and
about this and that and me and dj
premier are [ __ ] hanging out and
joking and clowning each other and you
know what i mean
big daddy kane i mean i could go on and
on with these legends that i've met that
just show me so much respect and i'm
like
these are the people i love and
appreciate and they've always embraced
me i think it's this like concept of
uh you know like i remember the source
magazine gave
eminem like one mic or something out of
five mics that was like the thing back
then and it was like he was pissed off
and
rightfully so his albums were really
amazing especially back then in that
time
um but that acceptance in a culture when
you look at a lot of the people who are
accepted it's almost like how long do
they even really last
right that's what's funny in that in
that circle
um but i love hip-hop and i've always
loved hip-hop and it's just
was a weird thing to kind of hear drake
say that and i'm like no one is immune
to it you know i've had some
i've had some thug rapping gangsta
[ __ ] call my phone and be like
bro i don't live this life
at all like sure i wa there was a time
when i was around it but i
i never shot nobody i've never but i
feel like i need to perpetuate this
lifestyle on the record so that i can
sell records and that if i don't then
i'm just gonna be a nobody but i also
feel like
the fact that i'm wrapping these things
are bringing that negative energy
towards me and all this [ __ ] and i'm
like man i'm so glad
i'm rapping about like cowboy bebop and
[ __ ] right now
like it's it's a crazy place man a lot
of it is
is fake you know and it's just like a
fake
extra background and a lot of it is real
um
you know j cole j cole is like that's
like my brother man
that dude is so honest and so real with
what he talks about
and he's never really put on a front i
mean
besides like his mixtapes where he's
kind of like i mean we all do it where
he's like yeah i got this [ __ ] and she
bad and blah blah blah and it's like
but that's that's the big l like i don't
know if you guys ever listen to big l
or even reasonable doubt era jay-z like
there's something about braggadocio
in hip-hop that it's just like systemic
like i do
yeah everyone does it [ __ ] want to
[ __ ] me but i'm i'm reading
anime instead like that i'm just it's
something it's really weird
anyways why is it that you think what is
it about this
that people need to front like they're
killing people and
selling drugs and all this [ __ ] you know
what i mean um
well here's the thing right if you take
somebody like two chains
or um different people who've actually
done this at the end of the day
they're they're still rapping about
their lives so
um it it is bittersweet because i don't
[ __ ] with like negativity or
um promoting [ __ ] gang violence or
any of that other [ __ ] but it also is a
way of life
you know so if that's all you know is
compton
and the street or whatever the case may
be and a family
that embraced you regardless of
literally what the color of their flag
might be uh
more than your own [ __ ] parents you
know that either weren't there for you
or you were a crack baby and nobody ever
gave a [ __ ] about you
and then you're 11 and you join
a gang of people who really actually do
become your family now even though they
might be involved in some illicit [ __ ]
or whatever it's like
this is low-key what like white america
doesn't understand
like they don't understand that this is
what you were born into and it's all you
know and you never
even really have an opportunity there
are a lot of people in the hood who are
super woke educated
doing great things not everyone's a
[ __ ] criminal that's like [ __ ]
racist
view um but when i do hear some of these
rappers
rap about that particularly the young
kids they're really doing that if you
listen to mob deep you know
prodigy i'm only 19 but my mind is older
like this dude was 19 years old
in queens selling drugs like you know
nas was doing the same
thing and but nas was also studying the
dictionary and the thesaurus and
and and doing what he could to tell the
story of
of his hood um in a beautifully art
articulate way
and then through that he rose above it
and kind of got out of that mind you he
still visits and
takes care of his people and his brother
and all that other [ __ ] so
i think like any young person that i
hear
kind of perpetuating the gang violence
there's a part of me that's like a
little saddened but at the same time
it's like talk your [ __ ] black man like
that that is what you know don't try to
don't try to act like that's not the
[ __ ] life you were born into
like you were born into that and now
you're blessed enough to be here i mean
why do you think rappers buy chains doug
because it's a it's a it shows that you
made it
right and even though it's kind of might
seem like
ignorant to an outside source or
whatever it's like that's all they ever
had and that's all they ever knew and
the people that they looked up to
wore those chains and did those things
and then i think it takes a very strong
uh man to make it out of that
while truly educating himself and
understanding so like me
personally i didn't buy a bunch of
chains i didn't buy a bunch of [ __ ] i
didn't buy rolex until i was 28 years
old
and going to the grammys and i was like
and i wanted one my whole life
and had been able to afford it for six
years up until that point
and for me i think allowing
there's just a lot it's man it's very
difficult when
when trying to discuss this because
putting down
a rapper for rapping about his life is
kind of [ __ ] you know
especially when they're so young but i
think if you're 30 something years old
talking about oh my cue you [ __ ]
i'm gonna put a bullet in you it's kind
of like
damn man you've been you've been in the
rap game for like five years
and then that's when i get those calls
by certain people like that who are like
yo i don't live this life anymore
but i and then so you find that they
themselves are torn i have a song
on my last album oh what were we going
to say nothing
like just kind of stuck in a rut like
music almost artistically where they
have this style and then
they're kind of stuck in it 100 yeah
um i have this song called cocaine on my
last album that i did before this one
and it goes uh the hook is cocaine
cocaine cocaine cocaine molly
percocet my rep move up like a dolly if
i talk about this [ __ ] more often
probably
so what i was doing is it was kind of
like a social experiment
and i was doing these things called
freestyle fridays where every friday on
instagram i would release like a
60-second snippet
and so that's what i did cocaine cocaine
cocaine cocaine molly
percocet my rep move up right and then
it goes into the verse and the verse is
uh
[ __ ] how does it go do you know how it
goes justin i forget
oh i ain't never [ __ ] with no sneak
dis best basket off my dick
boy you better not repeat this cocaine
would i flip jump in the whip cannot
compete with a real og like me you know
i get that dough like deep dish
got the party jumping in atlanta like
i'm freaknik got the party jumping in
atlanta like i'm donald glover
i don't want no good girl i only want a
freak [ __ ] a [ __ ] without a rubber
like i'm saying all this like really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] right now the cool thing
is
is it's wrapped from two perspectives
it's wrapped from the perspective of a
cocaine
drug dealer and it's also wrapped from
the perspective of cocaine itself
as if cocaine is telling the story i
only [ __ ] a [ __ ] raw
like you know what i mean because it's
like raw like your nose and all this
other stuff
so i put that out and for the most part
people were like this is
amazing like this is crazy like and then
you had some people who were like logic
what the [ __ ] you talking about like
this isn't you
this isn't whatever right and then on
the album the second verse came up
and the second verse is the perspective
of that rapper who's rapping as this
drug dealing guy
basically saying um what the [ __ ] are
the
lyrics i forget the goddamn lyrics no
it's like really important i'm gonna
look it up for you because
sorry i got so much [ __ ] in my hand yeah
i don't play anymore
um logic lyrics one second because it's
very
okay here we go i got him damn that's so
weird i can just lift up your own head
yeah i know um uh i don't
so so i'm going to read this to you i
never [ __ ] with no sneak diss best
get off my dick boy you better not
repeat this cocaine would i flip jump
into whip cannot compete with a real og
like me
you know i get that dough like deep dish
got the party jumping in atlanta like
i'm freaking it got the party jumping in
atlanta like i'm donald glover i don't
want no good girl i'm thinking i need a
freak [ __ ] i don't want no good girl
cause your boy he ain't no lover
[ __ ] her with no rubber then i bounce
back smoking on some [ __ ] so good i
can't even
pronounce that shawty drop it low and
make it bounce back smoking on some [ __ ]
so good i can't even pronounce now it's
cocaine cocaine cocaine cocaine molly
second verse i don't really want to
glorify it but the streets glorify it so
i gotta glorify it before the people
throw a riot if i don't talk about it on
my album then they won't buy it man [ __ ]
that listen up
quiet they want to see a black man fall
down they want to see a black man lose
they want to see a black man fall down
they want to see uh they want more
blacks to sing the blues
and then i repeat this um bank don't
want to give me a loan for my house
that's why i sell bricks of cocaine by
the gas station
never had a foundation white man's
stripped it from my people on the
plantation
hope somebody praying for all the
salvations even though this is the
dialogue inside of my brain i'm filled
with pain but i just can't seem to
refrain from
cocaine cocaine cocaine cocaine molly
now here's
what's really funny about the internet
is that i've seen a lot of people say
that i ruined the song with the second
verse that when the album came out and
they heard the second
the second verse oh he ruined the whole
song so it's funny to think that me
what i was doing more as a social
experiment which is really what
confessions of a date it's what that
whole album is it was like an experiment
to see what would happen if i just made
the most ignorant [ __ ] and had fun with
it
but anyway it's funny that that first
verse is [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
drugs and all this [ __ ] and then the
second verse
is what that person rapping right this
fictional rap character that actually
exists
in the world is saying i don't want to
do this i don't want to talk about this
you know they want they want to [ __ ]
tear the black man down they want to
paint us as this and this and that
and that by me saying that real stories
whether it's my brothers
other rappers i've come into contact
with who have told me these things and
how they
felt and and me witnessing it tear them
apart
ruin the song yeah that's odd exactly i
think
the message of not you know
uh one judging a book by its color but
also of a strong
man in general but a strong black man
wanting to stop
that uh negativity and turn his own life
around
ruin the song i thought that was funny
personally some people must have liked
it though
i hope yeah i mean those are the same
people in the arena that were screaming
in every lyric community
because because that that's more real
right i feel like
that's probably probably more relatable
to to who that person might
might be in real life because i mean
i've had a conversation with that person
who was like good job this is exactly
how i felt
yeah i mean what would you say as
someone who came out of kind of that
poverty and despair out of the hood and
has
totally kind of i don't want to say
escaped it how would you describe it i
mean you made it you made it out right
like from the outside looking in now
kind of like
what can we do to like help that
situation
to make it better because it seems it
definitely is like a tale of two
worlds here it feels like uh in a lot of
cities or
even in the country itself where there's
like white america as you described it
just doesn't understand
and can't really understand what is it
like to grow up in a hood
and i think that's where a lot of
prejudice and racial
racism stems from is because you can't
you can't understand what it's like to
grow up there
and then and then you you judge these
people
based on the based on your upbringing
right
yeah i think it's [ __ ] i think it's
systemic racism and it's
um it's just how it is it's like these
are people who aren't necessarily
as educated as they could possibly be
because of
their school districts and systems and
the lack of funds
and i mean [ __ ] i was yeah my school
system utterly failed me like nobody
told me i could be whatever i wanted to
be or do whatever i wanted because
they tell you that as a child they say
shoot for the dreams be
you know shoot for your dreams be
whatever you want do this the stars all
this other [ __ ] then you do it and they
caught they say it's unrealistic you
know what i mean
and um it's really sad when you see
such incredibly smart young people um
you know that are not given
the same opportunities that yeah like
some rich white kid
growing up in a good you know county or
suburb or whatever
um is receiving at the same time it's
not that
kid's fault you know what i mean that
that he's has a good education and
you know his parents or whatever it's
really about the country not to get all
crazy political and all this [ __ ] but
it's like it's about
how things have been set up and how
certain people
of color are just not given the upper
hand at
[ __ ] all and it's a really sad thing
to see but that's why it's always
it's also really beautiful when you see
these
amazing people make it out and i don't
mean rappers and i don't mean actors i
mean doctors and lawyers
and uh you know people who are the real
heroes who make a difference and make a
change
and and make it in their community dude
that [ __ ] is like
so beautiful and i think it's amazing
but
i can't even really talk too much about
this because it's like i don't know how
the [ __ ] to fix it bro
talk to killer mike yoshi yo you guys
ever interviewed mike no but i don't
know we would love to
yeah i'll check i'll text him for you
that'd be an awesome conversation yeah
he's the [ __ ] man dog he's so cool
i think i feel like a lot of people
don't understand systemic racism like
for me there's one easy way it's not
even maybe
this doesn't prove racism as much as
like classism
when you say local property tax funds
schools
so when you're in a poor neighborhood
where the medium
house value is eighty thousand dollars
yeah you're going to get
so much less money than in a nice
neighborhood where the medium house is a
million dollars
i mean there you go just a loan you're
gonna get 10 times more money
so that that that's [ __ ] up like when
you when you just think
like poor neighborhood should these kids
should be entitled to
receive just as good of an education as
rich people
otherwise you're just going to
perpetuate the issue of of
of class yeah class is a big
big part of it right it isn't
necessarily just
just race it's not the black and the
white card it's
glass but let's just come on doug like
look okay sure yeah yeah yeah no i mean
well when you and another thing is like
when when you're coming off the back of
150 years of slavery of not having
nothing
it take and then and then another 100
years of state
sponsored racism in the form of like jim
crow
it's like dude you don't just
you don't just accumul accumulate wealth
and equality
yeah 100 that's why that's why i have
that speech at the end of my album from
orson welles from 1946
which still love so relevant today yeah
man like
um i agree and i think you know it's
good to talk about
but it's another thing to really like i
think it's cool that you know
you've educated yourself i saw that one
video that you did about
how you were quite ignorant to what was
going on um and you were you were you
were telling the story how you had
gotten pulled over oh [ __ ] and all that
you're freaking out
and that's that's real i think a lot of
people uh
white people are are actually just very
ignorant to what is going on and they
don't understand it they literally don't
get it because
you know um i think more and more now
uh with people speaking out um it's
it's great and i've even you know i've
seen it in a weird way i remember when
uh
i remember when uh the black lives
matter really like exploded the movement
and i
it was a very beautiful thing i then had
people being like why aren't you
hashtagging black lives matter and like
even having like little white kids like
be like oh what are you not black enough
you're not
doing this and i felt it was like really
crazy and i called killer mike because i
was like bro
i'm actually making an album about all
this that's going on in the world right
now this is for the album everybody
and i was like i'm i'm really talking
about this but i don't want to feel like
i have to hashtag some [ __ ] i want to
make an album so that it's going to live
forever and it and i just say this to
say that it's like
i see i have seen on the internet where
it kind of is also like a fad
where it's like the cool thing to do i'm
just being real like it's the cool thing
to like hashtag this if you're like this
white suburban kid who has no [ __ ]
idea what's going on
but then they're not actually doing
anything about it and i have that where
i've said
uh yeah i think yeah on hit my line
people on twitter bitchin
uh evil politicians people on twitter
[ __ ] and hashtag it but in real life
they never pitch in
and it's like that that's one thing
that's like okay it's cool
all right you know these like young kids
that
are aware because they watch a video and
that's amazing but like what the [ __ ]
are you really like doing though
and it's i don't mean you gotta you know
you don't have to go out and march on
washington and [ __ ] but like to actually
in your own life like change your your
perception of how you view
people of color and and you deal with
that i think i think it's really
important but i think it is happening
too hopefully i don't sound like an
idiot i'm just kind of no you don't know
no your point is really valid i think i
think it's it's probably good
at least that it's even fashionable but
i think you're right that a lot of
people
you know it's fun howard stern i know
it's it's
to reference another show but he always
has a really good anecdote about
he grew up in new york and amongst super
liberal people that were always all
pro-black rights and equality and stuff
but he said they were the first people
when a black family would move into the
neighborhood that they were the first
people to bounce in the middle of the
night
because the black family brought the
property value
down so i thought that was always an
interesting insight that he was like
yeah you can
you could say you're liberal and say all
all this
[ __ ] but when it comes down to it
they're the first people out of that
neighborhood
yeah it's pretty crazy man times have
time times are changing and there's been
yeah there's
it's funny because yes has there been
progress a hundred [ __ ] percent but
it's like
progress dog like how are we even in a
world where like racism i can't believe
it it's
but there's a part of me that just
believes
change 100 can happen major major change
is happening has happened will continue
to happen
but it's going to be a fight forever
like when you have light you have
darkness you know where you have good
you have evil
and um and it's it's going to be a long
fight man but i'm here to i'm here to
fight
and and help however i can and i know
you guys are too and that's or we
wouldn't be talking about this right now
and that's very important
but yeah do you have any reoccurring
dreams
yeah actually recently i had a dream uh
i had a dream about
call of duty i was because i wasn't
playing a lot of call of duty and then i
had this weird dream about
jake paul oh really yeah and i had it
like twice
and i forget what was happening he was
in jail
and uh something about like playing
chess or something it was really weird
the reason why that happened
is because i'd never watched a jake paul
youtube video in my life and i was like
oh man
maybe it'd be kind of funny because i
think it wasn't something happening he
just got raided or something right by
that
i was watching your podcast and i was
like oh [ __ ] jake paul got
raided that's crazy all right so then i
like saw that and i just kind of like
looked into it and i was like let me
like
i've never seen this dude's videos ever
so let me go look at them
and they're just hilarious it's like
softcore porn oh yeah
yeah yeah i mean also i'm not like a
hater you know whatever i don't know
like i'm just it just was like kind of
funny and then i saw this music video he
did
um and he he actually can rap
that's what's actually it's funny he can
rap
um but it's like hilarious you know i'm
not trying to shoot on jake paul i don't
know this guy yeah i mean
i'm just saying it's every day bro was
his breakout uh
debut some of the greatest rapping in
the world it's everyday bro
oh that was that's what it is no i don't
know i just saw this recent one with
like a bunch of fast cars
yeah yeah it was called girls straight
out of london i believe
yeah something and then i don't know
anyway i just thought it was funny but i
just because i wanted to do my
my research for once on this guy because
i
heard about him so i was just watching
all this and it's yeah he's just got
like all these girls and everything's
like click bait
but the weird thing though is like that
dude does put a lot of
at least i think so effort into his
videos because
you can see it's like watching a reality
television show like it really feels
like
yeah i obviously scripted and all this
like he puts a lot of effort into it so
i was like sitting there watching it
and i was like okay i'm [ __ ] done and
then i go to sleep and i'm like no
you were there yeah no it was it was
cool it was it was like entertaining but
yeah those those guys work hard there's
no doubt
you can say what you want about them but
they do work hard for sure
are you are you bummed out that you
can't uh tour your new album
are you kind of really no i was i took
off that's the funny thing about this uh
is i took off this whole year i wasn't
gonna you were gonna do it anyway
yeah with uh with my son and my my wife
so
i wasn't gonna do it anyway and then
even when i do tour again though it's
gonna be very different i'm not gonna do
this big
eventually excuse me down the road i
will but
the next tour i do is going to be
smaller venues and by small i mean like
i don't know three to five thousand
people instead of [ __ ] 22 000 people
and it's to be me a dj and a [ __ ]
microphone and like some cheap
background
i want to just rap i just want to just
go out on stage
and spit poems and interact i'm
literally going to let people know like
if you want to come see me on tour it's
not like hey baby you want to go to
logic concert and pop molly and look at
all the lights like that's not happening
like you're going to come out there
and appreciate the music and that's just
what i'm on man i've just changed my
whole
my whole vibe like i made my money i had
fun
you're a dad no yeah i i really am like
what am i
i love dad bod by the way that song rips
dead
thanks that was a fun one that was one
of the last songs that and then dark
place
where the last i love both of these
thank you thank you so much
how how um how true is dark place
because
the some of the lines there are pretty
are pretty dark for
lack of a better word is it reflective
of
is it maybe an older version of yourself
or do you still find yourself in
in the proverbial dark place i think
that was the
la it was like the it was like frieza's
form before his final form before like
gold freezing
that was like me uh at the cusp
of like creating this album and then
kind of in the beginning of the album
where i was and then by the end of the
album
i wasn't there and i think that's why i
could write that song and that was
originally going to be on that free
mixtape i was working on it wasn't even
on that beat it was on like somebody
else's beat
and uh and then i ended up making and my
friends were like dude you have to put
this on the album and i was like no
it's too like it's too vulnerable it's
too like for the math
it's like it's too yeah i was like it's
i feel like i'm whining
i feel like i sound like and me too i
really i'm glad i put it on so
yeah it was literally the last record
that we that we had made and um
i didn't it wasn't like i was clearing i
literally was turning in the album
and then everyone was like dude it's
just so good you got to put it on my boy
schwei
my engineer everybody was like do it so
i did that and yeah those lyrics are
very
they were very true at a time but not
not not now
um and but once again i'm not impervious
to um
you know human emotion and
all the [ __ ] that i talk about in that
song sure
we all i'm going to always feel that way
about certain things in my life
um but when it comes to rap and
acceptance and all this
race [ __ ] and all this i've really let
it go
as much as you can as my you know if i
hear tomorrow that somebody's talking
[ __ ] about me that i've never met or
shook their hand i might be like
wow that sucks but i'm also not gonna
let it like keep me up like it used to
you know
um did you know going into this album
that it would be your last like kind of
your retirement
or was there a specific moment when
you're like uh
[ __ ] i'm done with this [ __ ] was it
kind of just a vibe
that you were i've wanted i've wanted to
quit
for like five years there's been a part
of me that wanted to quit
there's a difference between i think
quitting and me then retiring
i wanted to quit from lack of feeling
accepted or this or all the [ __ ] and
the drama and the
you know exhaustion and the touring and
the money and the decimals and you know
doing [ __ ] because other people are in
your pocket and that is that and all the
[ __ ]
like that made me just want to be like
[ __ ] you like [ __ ] this
um i've wanted to make this album for a
while so
it's actually a loaded answer it's
really amazing though because that you
asked that question so i've wanted to
make this album for years
there's another album that i had been
hinting and alluding to called
ultra 85 which is like if if you have
under pressure which is my debut and
then you have the incredible true story
the album about space
i was always in my head like okay i'm
going to do no pressure and then i'm
going to do
ultra 85 which is the is basically the
mirror of those
later 10 years later or whatever and
while i was in the beginning of making
this probably like four months in
um i realized that the only reason i
wanted to do ult
ultra 85 is because oh look at the
duggar
alfredo alfredo alfredo it's because
i wanted i guess to please my fans
because i had kind of
uh teased this ultra 85 album and it's
gonna be my last album and all the [ __ ]
and while i was making this album i was
like this is it this feels good to me
this is this feels like what ultra 85
would have been
so i'm just gonna name it no pressure
and this
is gonna be it like i yeah i just don't
i have no
there's nothing inside of me that wants
to subject myself to
the form of rap entertainment anymore
you've got to be at least a little
relieved that
that people like it oh bro
[ __ ] amazing it does it's it's
yeah it's gotta feel [ __ ] good it
feels great because
for so long but here's here's why it's
so cool
after going through what i did with my
last album where it was like
overly hated and yet so
uh well-received uh as far as like
mainstream and numbers and all that
right
if i hadn't gone through that feeling of
like
everyone hating me the reception was
brutal man
yeah yeah it was then i wouldn't have
been able to
love myself because i was looking for
love and acceptance in others to fulfill
the void that was there
and when that album wasn't received how
i hoped it would have been received mind
you for me i was just like i'm just
making
[ __ ] like troll turn up music like
loki you know what i mean
but after it was received that way yeah
i spent a year and a half almost two
years
looking inside what really matters to to
me
um and not about the even the kind of
music
because it just further proves that i
could always make this music and that i
have already made this music i did four
mixtapes two albums three albums
whatever all this [ __ ] before getting to
this point where like logic wasn't cool
anymore or whatever the [ __ ]
because he's not making the music for
the people anymore and so i didn't make
this
album it's not a spite album i wasn't
like oh i'm going to prove everyone
wrong i was like oh i feel like doing
this now i
i feel like actually just i mean there's
only five hooks on the whole album
there's 15 tracks there's
it's just a open journal it's just
bars on bars on bars on bars it isn't
the structure like
hook verse eight bar bridge this which
i've done
it has been successful i was like this
is literally just
poetry and it's funny that i do
i did it and then everyone's like he's
back
like this is it this is amazing but it's
like i didn't go anywhere
all those lyrics all those raps all
those things were a part of me but i was
just doing other things i was trying to
do other things so i wasn't in a box
but did it feel good yes and the reason
i say all this is i wasn't on the
internet at all i didn't know what the
[ __ ] anybody was saying about me
i didn't know how it was being received
right at all
and then you know my manager people are
like yo it's kind of going it's gonna go
and we did you know 200 almost 225 or
whatever the [ __ ]
thousand units in the first week
which is also amazing but that's not why
i did it you know but it just it
it feels really good to know that i i
did something for my heart and then it
was
also so you know well received
by the people but the funny thing is
is i've got songs over here or i could
have done another
album that i just have sitting on here
of like pop-ass
post malone type [ __ ] i'm just being
real right not i mean you know he gets
his own hate and his love too
but i could have done some [ __ ] like
that which would have gotten way more
numbers
and made me way more money i'm not
barely making any money on this album
yeah
touring i mean that's pretty much no not
even that the actual
album bro has like 30 plus samples right
you have people it's like oh you use
this part for three seconds
okay that's 45 percent oh on that same
song you use this for
uh you know 4.8 seconds that's 20
percent
and then i have to split between it's
like a whole thing but i didn't give a
[ __ ] my team was like yo you know you're
not gonna make any money like
i had my lawyers like can't we just
change it or do it
originally and i'm like you have no idea
this is about the art i don't give a
[ __ ] about the money
they make it so hard to actually care
about the art though it's the same on
youtube in a way
yeah where it's they make it tough
man but i'm glad you did it that way
thanks
yeah but yes so long story short
it feels incredible to like kind of go
out like this because
it's it's what i could honestly there
was this
it's so funny though this reception is
the reception i
always wanted in hip-hop like and it's
funny that it's like when i'm leaving
yeah and i think though and i didn't
plan it this way if i did i would have
sold it
i'm retired this is the laughs
i'd have [ __ ] gone off and tried to
sell it that's why i kind of wanted to
underplay it like yeah i'm leaving and
here's my reasons
take it or leave it [ __ ] off it doesn't
i know the truth and in five years when
you're like he's coming back
you know what i mean like i'm not going
to come back um
[ __ ] was i saying i just forgot was it
going to say before then oh just that
it's so funny
getting the reaction you always wanted
it feels like
um you know for the last few years in
hip-hop it's like
oh memes and let's make fun of logic and
it's like the thing to make fun of me
because i was so popular and known
and then when i'm like hey y'all i'm
leaving then people are like
oh [ __ ] like not only can we not make
fun of this guy anymore but in a way
it's like
he's just been a source of entertainment
it's a low-hanging fruit it's easy to
make a biracial joke which is [ __ ] so
outplayed or
this or that or whatever the case may be
damn
this dude's really going and like he's
how i found hip-hop or
i discovered him when i was 12 years old
and now i'm [ __ ] 22.
oh my god this is crazy
it's almost like it's a posthumous album
without the death in a way it's
weird because people can sense the
severity that i am leaving and i'm being
true about it and because of that i
think they went
into the album because most people
regardless of any form of media are
going what can i [ __ ] on what can i [ __ ]
on as soon as like rather than like just
trying to enjoy something
and i think people really went into it
like okay
i want to enjoy this album from logic i
haven't really necessarily
maybe liked the last few things he did
and
i haven't [ __ ] with it personally or
this or that mind you this loud minority
this this group or whatever
but i really want this to be good and
then they sit down and they listen
and then they're listening for the
positive and the good in it
and it just so happens i killed the
[ __ ] album so they introduced me
yeah um so this is it
you're saying right now there's no in
five years
logic come back with the new album
you're not you
you sure you just don't need a break
maybe for a little bit are you gonna
is there any chance of you returning um
okay so
this is the thing like no i'm not coming
back i'm retired i just want to be a dad
shoot guns act in [ __ ] movies and
maybe like work on soundtracks or
something or maybe go [ __ ] make my
own gorillas
you know what i mean like as far as like
logic make your own gorillas
yeah like you know the gorillas the
group the band oh
okay yeah damon omer oh my god yeah he's
dope it's the guy from blur
do you know that band blur i don't but i
understand
song that goes like this it goes
you don't know that [ __ ] song no i
thought anyway
so that guy created the gorillas yeah i
got it and
in a way it's like if i could just focus
more on production
and like just bring other singers or
other rappers in or you know fun stuff
like that like i love music and i'll
always
make music and i want to find ways to be
able to release music
but as far as logic rapping about yo i
made it in a struggle in my life
and all this [ __ ] and logic logic is
done
i feel like i'm just you've taken it all
the way that you can
that whole persona yeah the only thing
that could be fun to do i think about
this i've talked to mad lib do you guys
know who mad lib is
mad lib is like a legendary producer
he's like um
a living j dilla if you will i'm sure
you might have heard of j dilla
legendary producer
and um you know we we we've actually
talked about doing an album together
which could be fun like when i think
about that that's different but the only
reason why i
would even think about that is because
when mad lib does an album with anybody
they become a group
so i wouldn't it wouldn't be me it would
be me a part of this thing with someone
else that's like creating something
super fun
the idea of that one-off kind of project
where i would actually be rapping again
sounds kind of fun but when we're
talking about like logic dropping
singles and albums and music videos like
that [ __ ] is
i i don't want to do it i have no urge
to do it
and yeah people make the you know the
jay-z well jay-z came back and this and
all this other [ __ ] it's like
okay as a human being right justin
bieber like never say never
you know what i mean but like i just
have no
i went out season nine seinfeld dog like
yeah why would i come back
like there's no reason for me to want to
do that michael jordan came back you
just don't know how you'll feel in five
years
yeah but i understand what you're saying
is like the uh
the logic story is over that makes sense
to me
and that's what the logic thing has
always been like when people listen to
logic like even in my turn up songs
there's still
something like a message or and i'm like
over that [ __ ] i'm like i've spent my
whole career being like
you can make it believe in yourself
peace love and positivity
yo black it's beautiful all this [ __ ]
and it's that it's all true
but i'm kind of tired i'm like i've
literally spent 10 years doing this
thing i kind of just want to have fun
and be a dad now like it's not that deep
yeah
yeah that's awesome man
well you certainly like you said season
nine
you did it dude although how does
seinfeld end they go to prison
yeah they go to prison and they have
their last conversation between jerry
and george is the very
first dialogue or the first episode ever
in the coffee shop
was it uh was it cereal they were
talking about the amount of milk no
they're talking about
his buttons yeah his buttons yeah yeah
that's pretty good
but you kind of did that too with the
reference to the first album
so we got a full cycle i think you did
it good man i love that album
yeah happy for you i appreciate it dude
it's
letting all that [ __ ] go is just like i
wake up now
and i just like my
my biggest thing now is like damn i'm
not like working out as much
you know what i mean like it's [ __ ] like
that like but even that in itself like
getting all yoked i've always felt like
a very weak weak weak weak person
and not even like physically like inside
i felt like a weak person because
my physique was also the scrawny tiny
little guy
and then i got 180 pounds of [ __ ]
muscle and i realized
none of this makes me any stronger
you know what i mean and then through
that i found strength
and you realize like it's just about
being healthy and it's like cool man
i as long as i'm healthy
that's all that matters and working out
is like [ __ ] annoying sometimes
but i think you i think you just get in
a zone you either like want to work out
or you don't but
i just like haven't been in a workout
mood
i still work out like minimum twice a
week i try to hit three days a week
and even that it's just like lifting and
like yeah that's pretty good
just for maintaining cardio but then
also
hiking and [ __ ] because i'm hiking out
here in montana so that's that's really
that's fun me and my wife will go out
and i'll ride the dirt bikes around oh
yeah
so i'm still getting exercise it's just
not like
my therapist she tells me once again i'm
too hard on myself you know
you're also a new dad and i think that
kind of
you're constantly tired i feel like at
least
at least i am yeah this is exhausting
yeah but these are the things that
honestly i'm happy to focus on like now
i'm like
yeah yeah you know and then it's so
funny because it's like well who do i
need to be
jacked [ __ ] hugh jackman for like you
know my wife's like
your dick works and i think you're hot
that's all that matters like you know i
mean
i'm joking but um no it's like i just
want to look good for her and she thinks
i'm
i'm handsome and that's all that matters
to me you know and that's how i feel
about her i think she's a beautiful
woman like
you know she doesn't need to be crazy
shredded or anything or this or that
it's just like
take care of yourself you know and do
the best that you can
and i think that's important so i've
just been focusing on that
i'm kind of jealous of the leaving you
know there's a whole phenomenon of
people leaving la
now a lot of like uh comedians comedians
and artists and people just in general
joe rogan obviously joe wrote a big one
i get it you know i feel like i'm i'm
forced to live here because of our
our career choice it's in your head so
well with the with the fashion and with
the podcast like right now there's covid
but
i can't imagine getting people in the
studio if i lived in like montana like
nobody's going to come monday yeah but
also look at this dude
like really look at this guy it proves
that like
especially if somebody gives a [ __ ] to
even if you
shipped out and paid like bro
you could totally do it you could have
somebody with like a dslr
type of camera or sony you know what i
mean show up you pay for a ticket for
somebody
with all these guys are like not me
don't send me how to [ __ ] all over
the
place
but you you do that and you literally
have them set it up it's like what ryan
seacrest does dude i've sat down with
ryan seacrest
he's in new york i'm in la they cut it a
certain way to make it for real
yeah like you're in the same studio and
they don't and the audience doesn't know
that you guys aren't in the same
i mean they probably do yeah but because
he talks about it and he says that but
it doesn't come off that way because i
didn't know that yeah i never even
thought
about that no but think about that if
you have somebody there with a camera
yeah you know a really good camera and
an sm7 hooked up you know through an
apollo through a macbook or something
just to capture the audio
yeah you have great quality but i think
um corona
has proved that you don't need
you don't need look at this you're going
to have all my fans here watching this
you're going to have your fans
everyone's going to be happy and excited
i'll tell you going into the covid we
were like oh [ __ ] we gotta go in our
basement
we can't have guests and and i was very
skeptical about having guests on
on zoom but i gotta say i i like it
i don't i actually think it's kind of
nice in a way it feels more casual
that's true where it's more yes being
with them in the first so it's a
different
you definitely get different energy but
i certainly
don't i certainly like it a lot more
than i thought it would
yeah and it doesn't even have to be like
that forever but it's just we give
ourselves these
these excuses you know you could say oh
with the fashion line i have to be here
because the office and then
you know the the people that i i work
with and art direction and that and
all this other [ __ ] or you could do what
you're doing right now and you're still
working on clothing
and you're still getting the job done
you're still doing it like this
just should almost prove that you can be
as happy as you want to
and still do that like yeah me acting
i was talking to joe because we're
shooting the show and i i have to go
back to l.a
so what i got to travel sometimes like
it's kind of cooler that way then you
then you appreciate it and then
you know and you have like a tunnel uh
would you say do you have a ton of land
at your house i'm on an acre i didn't
want to do it
yeah that's not crazy i didn't want to
do a uh
like a big because i'm getting this i'm
in like a neighborhood i didn't want to
do
middle of nowhere yeah because it's a
little spooky
yeah if i like broke my leg or something
you know what i mean yeah just like your
[ __ ] hour and a half for you
helicopter flight yeah now [ __ ] now yeah
like i
i like living in neighborhoods i like
that sense of of community
yeah knowing that somebody's there it's
dope though it's pretty cool man
it's a nice town and you know i'm just
out shooting guns and riding my dirt
bike all day
so that's so dope it's so fun man it's
like a vibe
retirement sounds good dude i don't know
when i'm gonna get it but
you can get it whenever you want bro
these are things that we put on
ourselves bro
because like here's the thing you can't
not
create both of you guys you're artists
like you can't not
so that's the funny thing when i was
telling myself originally like i want to
retire i want to retire i want to retire
i was also scared that that meant like
no more income i'm not going to be able
to
think about the people you guys employ
and work with like it's scary to be like
oh well if i'm done they're done what
the [ __ ] are they going to do first of
all yeah what is what are they
going to do you know but it's first
things first they're gonna be fine
i know you guys are like can you please
not sell them on this no no no
my guys will never find another job if
you if you [ __ ]
died or killed yourself everybody would
be fine
ian is unemployable
what i mean is is that all these people
can still work with you do you know what
i mean like it doesn't it's not the end
of that because that's what i thought
i was like bro i have employees i got a
guy right next to me right now that i
like
he has a daughter and i know that i pay
him every cent that he makes
to support his family that's just one
person that's like deep that gives me
anxiety to think about that
but i still have to selfishly go
well i don't give a [ __ ] like i have to
be healthy uh happy you hear that this
healthy
and focus on and focus on me but if i'm
all those things
i'm still going to be creating and
honestly be be creating
as an even better version of myself to
ensure that he gets a paycheck
so i just say if you ever want to step
away
yeah you guys are fine you'll be able to
continue to employ them
and do whatever the [ __ ] that you want
to do man just like if you're not happy
they're not happy bro i am
actually i am happy i don't want to give
that impression that's not what i mean
i'm happy getting away stepping away
from the h3 stuff
that was making me unhappy yeah yeah and
the podcast i
really like working with these guys and
having this whole kind of community
i love the we're kind of i just want to
figure out how to
get it make it better and make it more
engaging and just
like i want to keep it going for years
to the point where
i just i'm super unhappy with the
product still and i know that
hey this is all you have to do like
literally people tune in to what i just
wanted to be better i just want it to be
better
but it's great it's great like don't fix
what everything's broken
just like your therapist keeps telling
you we're totally like that we're like
so hard on ourselves yeah sucks
no you're not you're asking incredible
bro we've talked about race relations
depression anxiety health happiness
things that make
we've literally i think because we're
friends it's a lot easier to talk to you
i have a lot i have a really hard time
talking with like
people kind of cold and i just
sometimes the interviews are just
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] those people don't
book those people now yeah
that's the lesson yeah here's another
thing don't get me wrong it's like
you know sure book
a big person every once in a while
because people are going to want to see
that or know about that
but dude like i can't tell you there's a
lot of people that you guys have
interviewed together
and i'm like who the [ __ ] is this person
i don't even know who this is
that's the point you you want to i want
i watch
and i listen to discover new people and
new things and it doesn't matter
they're [ __ ] you know angelina jolie
famous or
you know they made a youtube video that
has a couple million views and it's
funny like
yeah that's why we i'm in the conflict
of like
when we have a lesser known guest first
of all the views are
are way less or not always but sometimes
and so that
that always just feels bad from an ego
point of view and then also because we
have sponsors
then they [ __ ] when the views are less
but but okay whatever that [ __ ] doesn't
matter
and then it does people just i mean yeah
it
does that because that that that that's
a part of
what affects the quality right because
you have more fun interviewing the
people that you guys
want to interview regardless of views
because you you
this is one thing i love about you
because this is how i feel when i'm in
the studio it doesn't matter if i'm
making some turn up trap song or some
super deep song
it's always from my heart when the song
is done
mixed and mastered then i go into
business mode like okay now how can i
market this and get the most out of it
so the fact that for the most part you
guys are doing interviews
with people you genuinely care about is
like why we listen
you know what i mean it's just is what
it is think about it when you have a
brad pitt on your show or some wild [ __ ]
like that
those aren't your fans really tuning in
that's like
brad pitt's fans and [ __ ] like that and
that's cool
yeah but but ultimately that's how you
grow the show too
which is also another objective right so
it's tough but
ultimately ultimately i do
think i'm a shitty interviewer and i
hate no you're not
i'm just kidding you're not you're great
you guys are both
fantastic thank you h3 [ __ ] yeah
exactly like for example dan
like uh zach used to be a super fan and
now he [ __ ] hates me
not true at all i love you zach's
actually my golden boy
but that's true for ian ian doesn't like
me anymore
yeah ian was never a fan he faked it
dude his brother is a super fan
your mic dan what'd you say oh i was
just saying that uh we found out
recently that ian
ian uh snaked his brother's fandom to
get in with us
because ian wasn't really the fan it was
[ __ ]
ian wrote me a bunch of cold emails
looking for
to become an intern saying he was like a
huge fan and [ __ ]
but that that's not why he just he was
really persistent and he wrote really
good email so i was like [ __ ] it let's
give this guy a shot
that's cool we love ian but we recently
found out his brother's the super fan
and he didn't know anything about us so
he's a [ __ ] fake ass fan
that's not true i liked your guys's
videos
yo um before i moved i was out
driving and i was with my wife and my
security guard
and i saw this kid these three little
skaters where and they were wearing the
um
the the hat what's the one the teddy for
the one with the little
it's like a design like this it's like a
little teddy you know what i'm talking
about and it's like almost like a
corduroy looking hat oh yeah the thirty
fresh
it's like two bears the crest yeah yeah
yeah that's my favorite one
and you guys actually gave me one and i
[ __ ] lost
it oh i'll tell you another one
well you're sweet no we'll send you a
bunch of [ __ ] it'll be great thank you
so i see uh my wife loves it too so
we'll share she wears all my [ __ ] anyway
so um i see these kids
and i'm like yo do a kick flip
and they're like logic and i was like
[ __ ] yeah let me come out and i got out
of my i got out of the car and i did a
nollie flip on this kid's board and he
was like whoa
yeah anyway it's just a fun story
because i stopped because of the cool
hat they had
that's fine i wish i could do a kick
flip then people would like me
all right well it's been awful it's been
great man i love having you on here
yeah and i'm just so happy i was i
really loved the album i'm just so happy
that it uh
that you were able to get that get that
just i don't know everything you got you
know what i mean it's just it's
i'm just so happy the way it turned out
at the end for you thanks
it was a bit of a hurrah moment and it's
funny because of course i always cared
and i would have loved it
so when i say it's funny how it happens
when you don't even care like
i you always care but it didn't matter
to me anymore you know and then when it
didn't matter
it happened so it means a lot i'm happy
how long have we been [ __ ] talking
right now
it's been a minute two and a half hours
or something geez bro that's like a
[ __ ] christmas how long has it been
yeah i know i think it's
two and a half years yes that's good wow
no um i just want to say thank you guys
um thank you everyone dan zach
ian um ethan and ela for
always going hard and and really
supplying fans with
incredible content and um yeah man
seriously like i [ __ ] love you guys
and it really is a team
you know and and one thing i really
respect about you both
is that you let it be known that it is
also a team and you don't just try to
like take
everything for yourself and that's
really uh really special and
humble of you and um yeah i'm just
i just i don't know yeah i really
appreciate you guys and
and i don't know man it's so weird
because like me and my wife are such
fans of you
that's so nice i can't believe it thank
you guys so much and
you guys are so sweet we're happy for
you guys
we already have one n-word
[ __ ] love that clip dude all right
dope um
any last minute questions you can think
of no i think we've said it all
we've said it all we've done it all
we'll have to do a
play date bobby hall senior and junior
yeah we gotta meet bobby the third yeah
we should come we should come
come on tana come to your four-story
house
you actually should come through like
it's really dope and you have guest
rooms and all that stuff it'll be really
fun
but um all right remember to create from
the heart
have fun and i i appreciate you guys
thanks man same thing right back to you
god bless
peace out are we doing the actual piece
where i like leave or are we doing the
like oh it's cut
i think
[Music]
dude